Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode contains violence against children that won't be suitable for all listeners. It was a barmy afternoon in the United States capital of Washington, D.C. on Sunday, April 25, 1971. Allentine Spinks left her apartment on Walla Place, southeast in Congress Heights to visit
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用上或我们网站上的本集节目简介。本集的开头包含针对儿童的暴力内容，并非所有听众都适合收听。1971年4月25日星期日，美国首都华盛顿特区迎来了一个晴朗炎热的下午。阿伦汀·斯平克斯（Allentine Spinks）离开了她位于东南区国会高地（Congress Heights）沃拉坊（Walla Place）的公寓，去拜访
an aunt who lived on the other side of town. Before she left, Allentine warned her children they were not to leave while she was gone. Her 24-year-old daughter Valerie lived in a different apartment within the same complex. At around 7pm, she dropped in to ask if one of the older children could do her a favour by running out to buy some groceries from the nearby 7-Eleven convenience store. She knew their mother would disapprove, but it was a trip the youngest Spinks children had made many times before, and Valerie trusted them to take the seven-block journey alone. 13-year-old Carol agreed to complete the errand, tempted by the offer of a free soda.
一位住在城另一头的姑妈。离开前，阿伦汀警告她的孩子们，在她不在家的时候绝对不准出门。她24岁的女儿瓦莱丽（Valerie）住在同一个小区里另一间公寓里。晚上7点左右，瓦莱丽顺道过来，问较大的几个孩子能不能帮个忙，跑一趟去附近的7-Eleven便利店买点杂货。她知道这样做会遭到母亲的反对，但斯平克斯家年纪最小的孩子们以前已经去过很多次了，瓦莱丽信任他们，让他们独自完成这趟七个街区的路程。13岁的卡罗尔（Carol）禁不住免费汽水的诱惑，答应跑这趟腿。
Valerie handed her little sister a $5 bill and instructed her to purchase a loaf of bread, five TV dinners, and the drink for herself. As Carol sat out wearing blue gym shorts and a red sweater, she soon ran into her mother who was returning from her day out. Allentine was not pleased that Carol had disobeyed her orders. She told her to continue with the errand but to come straight home afterwards where she would then be punished. Carol agreed and hurried off to the store.
瓦莱丽递给小妹妹一张5美元的钞票，吩咐她买一条面包、五份冷冻微波套餐，以及她自己要喝的饮料。卡罗尔穿着蓝色的运动短裤和红色的毛衣出门，没走多远就遇到了外出归来的母亲。看到卡罗尔违背了自己的命令，阿伦汀很不高兴。她告诉卡罗尔继续去跑腿，但买完后必须马上回家接受惩罚。卡罗尔答应了，急匆匆地赶往商店。
Three hours passed and Carol still hadn't returned home. And her family contacted friends and neighbours to see if anyone had heard from her. They also contacted the 7-Eleven and to the clerk explained that Carol had entered the store at around 7.40pm. She purchased the items her sister had requested, but there had been no sightings after that. Allentine called the Washington Metropolitan Police and reported her daughter missing. The 40 members of the local community joined the Spinks family in scouring the neighbourhood and surrounding areas and door-knocking homes.
三个小时过去了，卡罗尔仍然没有回家。她的家人联系了朋友和邻居，看是否有人听到过她的消息。他们还联系了7-Eleven，店员向他们解释说，卡罗尔大约在晚上7点40分进入了商店。她买了她姐姐要求的东西，但那之后就再也没有人见过她。阿伦汀打电话给华盛顿大都会警察局，报案称女儿失踪。当地社区的40名居民加入了斯平克斯一家的行列，在社区及周边地区进行搜寻，并挨家挨户敲门询问。
The search continued for days, but there were no sightings or contact from Carol. Six days later, at approximately 2pm on Saturday, May 1, 1971, several children were playing on an embankment outside the St Elizabeth Hospital alongside the Suitland Parkway at a busy 9-mile freeway in southeast Washington. An 11-year-old boy wandered away from the group onto a grassy mound where he came upon the body of a young girl. He waved down a passing police patrol car. The body was identified as that of Carol Spinks, who was dressed in the same clothes that she
搜寻工作持续了好几天，但没有任何关于卡罗尔的目击情报或消息。六天后，即1971年5月1日星期日大约下午2点，几个孩子在位于华盛顿东南区一条繁忙的9英里高速公路旁、苏特兰公园大道（Suitland Parkway）旁伊丽莎白圣公会医院（St Elizabeth Hospital）外的路堤上玩耍。一个11岁的男孩从这群孩子身边走开，来到一个长满草的小土丘上，在那里他偶然发现了一具年轻女孩的尸体。他向一辆路过的警巡逻车挥手求助。经辨认，尸体正是卡罗尔·斯平克斯，她身上穿着的衣服和她
had been wearing on the day she left home, minus her shoes. From the way she was positioned on her back, it appeared as though Carol had either been thrown down the embankment from the freeway or had been dragged to the location. An autopsy concluded she had been sexually assaulted and strangled, with her death occurring two to three days before she was found. Green fibres were recovered on her body and undigested citrus fruit was found in her stomach. Carol's family confirmed she had not consumed any citrus fruit on the day she went missing. This detail, combined with the level of decomposition, indicated that her killer had likely fed and
离家那天穿的一模一样，只是鞋子不见了。从她仰面躺着的姿势来看，卡罗尔似乎是从高速公路上被扔下路堤的，或者是被人拖到这个地点的。尸检得出结论称，她曾遭到性侵并被勒死，死亡时间在她被发现前的两到三天。人们在她的尸体上发现了绿色纤维，胃里则发现了未消化的柑橘类水果。卡罗尔的家人证实，她在失踪当天没有吃过任何柑橘类水果。这一细节结合尸体腐烂的程度表明，凶手很可能在绑架后喂养并
kept her alive for several days after her abduction. News of Carol Spinks' murder received very little coverage in the media. The police did not disclose whether they had any leads or suspects, and revealed very little about their investigative efforts into identifying her killer. On the morning of Thursday, July 8, 1971, 16-year-old Darlenia Johnson woke and prepared herself for the day ahead. She lived on Wheeler Road, southeast in Congress Heights, just a few blocks from the Spinks apartment, and attended the same school as Carol, although the two girls didn't know
将她活了好几天。有关卡罗尔·斯平克斯谋杀案的新闻在媒体上受到的关注极少。警方没有透露他们是否掌握任何线索或嫌疑人，也极少透露他们为寻找凶手而展开的调查工作。1971年7月8日星期星期四早晨，16岁的达勒尼亚·约翰逊（Darlenia Johnson）醒来，为即将开始的一天做准备。她住在东南区国会高地的惠勒路（Wheeler Road），距离斯平克斯家的公寓只有几个街区，和卡罗尔上的是同一所学校，尽管两个女孩并不认识
one another. Darlenia had recently landed a summer job as a youth counselor at the Oxon Run Recreation Center, which was close enough to her home that she could walk to and from work each day. That day, in addition to her regular shift, she would be staying at the rec center overnight as they were holding a special sleepover for the kids in the neighborhood. Darlenia dressed in a green sweater, blue blouse, blue shorts, and a red, white and blue striped miniskirt, and reminded her mother not to expect her home that night.
彼此。达勒尼亚最近找到了一份暑期工作，在奥克森龙娱乐中心（Oxon Run Recreation Center）担任青年辅导员。这个中心离她家很近，她每天都可以步行上下班。那天除了例行值班外，她还准备在娱乐中心过夜，因为他们要为社区的孩子们举办一场特别的留宿活动。达勒尼亚穿着一件绿色毛衣、蓝色衬衫、蓝色短裤以及一条红白蓝三色相间的迷你裙，并提醒母亲今晚不用等她回家。
She said goodbye and began her walk to work, heading down the same street Carol Spinks traversed nine weeks earlier. Later that evening, Darlenia's mother, Helen, was informed that her daughter had failed to show up for work. She immediately called friends and neighbors, but nobody had seen Darlenia or had any idea where she could be. Helen spent the night sick with worry, hoping Darlenia would walk through the door. But when there still hadn't been any sign of her by the next morning, Helen contacted
她道了别，开始步行去上班，走的是九周前卡罗尔·斯平克斯走过的那条街。当天傍晚，达勒尼亚的母亲海伦（Helen）接到通知，称她的女儿没有去上班。她立刻打电话给朋友和邻居，但没有人见过达勒尼亚，也不知道她会在哪里。海伦心急如焚地熬过了一夜，期盼着达勒尼亚推门而入。然而直到第二天早上依然不见她的踪影，海伦便联系了
the Washington Metropolitan Police Department and filed a missing person report. A week later, a driver on the Interstate 295 Highway was having car trouble and pulled over, stopping 15 feet from where Carol Spinks' body had been found. There, within the heavy brush, he noticed what looked like a human body and called the police. There was the second call they had received that morning about a possible sighting of human remains in the area. A patrol car was sent out to investigate, but the dispatched officers drove by the site
华盛顿大都会警察局并报案称人口失踪。一周后，州际295号公路上一名司机的汽车出了故障，将车停在了距离发现卡罗尔·斯平克斯尸体15英尺远的地方。在那里，茂密的灌木丛中，他注意到疑似一具人类尸体，于是报了警。这是他们那天早上接到关于该地区可能出现人类遗骸的第二通电话。警方派出一辆巡逻车前往调查，但出警的警员驱车经过现场，
without getting out of their vehicle. To see a body, they deduced it was a false sighting and left the scene. On Monday, July 19, 11 days after Darlenia went missing, one of the witnesses returned to the side of the highway, curious to know the outcome of their grim discovery. To their surprise, the body was still in the same place it had been when they reported it days prior. This time, when the police were called, they located the body. Exposure to the hot summer weather had left the body heavily decomposed and it was not
甚至都没有下车。他们凭空臆断说看到尸体是个假警情，随后便离开了现场。7月19日星期一，即达勒尼亚失踪11天后，其中一位目击者重返高速公路旁，想看看他们这一骇人发现的结果如何。令他们惊讶的是，尸体依然原封不动地躺在几天前他们报警时的那个地方。这一次，当警察被叫来时，他们找到了尸体。夏日炎炎的高温暴晒导致尸体严重腐烂，当时已
possible to make an immediate identification. The remains were taken to the county coroner's office, where fingerprints and clothing were used to identify the body to be Darlenia Johnson. The 16-year-old was fully clothed in the outfit she was last seen wearing, and just like Carol Spinks, her shoes were also missing. Decomposition prevented the coroner from determining the cause of death or if she had been sexually assaulted. Once again, the police conducted door knocks in the Congress Heights area seeking any information
无法立即进行辨认。遗体被送往县验尸官办公室，通过指纹和衣物最终确认死者正是达勒尼亚·约翰逊。这名16岁的女孩身上完整地穿着她最后一次露面时穿的衣服，而且就像卡罗尔·斯平克斯一样，她的鞋子也不翼而飞。由于尸体腐烂，验尸官无法判定死因，也无法确定她是否遭到过性侵。警方再次在国会高地地区挨家挨户走访，以搜寻有关
about the teenager's death. One witness reported seeing Darlenia getting into an old black car being driven by a black male. Six days before Darlenia's body was discovered, a motorist driving roughly 25 miles south of Washington along Highway Route 228 in Waldorf, Maryland, spotted a body on the side of the road. It was 14-year-old Angela Barnes who had disappeared a week earlier on Monday, July 12, after leaving a friend's house at 11.45pm to walk the 10 blocks to her home on Martin
这名少女死因的任何线索。一名目击者报告称，曾看到达勒尼亚上了一辆由一名黑人男子驾驶的旧黑色汽车。在达勒尼亚的尸体被发现的六天前，一名司机在华盛顿以南大约25英里的马里兰州华尔道夫（Waldorf）沿228号公路行驶时，在路边发现了一具尸体。死者是14岁的安吉拉·巴恩斯（Angela Barnes）。她于一周前的7月12日星期一失踪，当时她离开一个朋友家，晚上11点45分动身步行走10个街区回她在国会高地
Luther King Junior Avenue in Congress Heights. Angela was bound fully clothed with a fatal gunshot wound to the back of her head. Connections were immediately drawn between her murder and that of Carol Spinks and Darlenia Johnson, but there were some differences. While Carol and Darlenia had both been strangled in what appeared to be a sexually motivated attack and disposed of near where they were last seen, Angela showed no signs of sexual assault and had been shot, then left a considerable distance from her last known whereabouts. All three girls were fully clothed, but Angela still had shoes on, whereas Carol and Darlenia
马丁·路德·金初级大道（Martin Luther King Junior Avenue）的家。安吉拉被捆绑着，衣着完整，后脑勺有致命的枪伤。人们立刻将她的谋杀案与卡罗尔·斯平克斯和达勒尼亚·约翰逊的案件联系起来，但其中存在一些差异。卡罗尔和达勒尼亚都是在疑似有性动机的袭击中被勒死，且抛尸地点都在她们最后露面附近，而安吉拉则没有显示出性侵迹象，她是遭枪击身亡，且被抛弃在距离她最后已知行踪相当远的地方。三个女孩都衣着完整，但安吉拉还穿着鞋子，而卡罗尔和达勒尼亚
did not. However, the similarities were also uncanny. All three victims lived in the Congress Heights area and were of similar age, race and appearance. They were all abducted while walking the streets of their neighborhood and their bodies had been left on the side of a highway. The police were reluctant to admit that all three murders were carried out by the same perpetrator, but couldn't ignore the similarities. Three young women being violently murdered under similar circumstances in less than a
则没有。然而，相似之处也同样诡异得令人毛骨悚然。三名受害者都住在国会高地地区，年龄、种族和外貌都很相似。她们都是在自己社区的街道上行走时被绑架的，并且尸体都被抛弃在高速公路旁。警方不愿承认这三起谋杀案是同一名凶手所为，但又无法忽视这些相似之处。三名年轻女性在不到三个月的时间里
three month period should have been major news, but the cases were receiving very little media coverage. Many members of the community believed it was due to the color of the victim's skin. In 1971, DC was in a state of racial turmoil. Three years earlier, in April 1968, Nobel Peace Prize-winning Baptist minister and civil rights activist Reverend Martin Luther King Jr. was assassinated in Tennessee during a visit to support African American public sanitary workers. As one of the leading and most influential advocates fighting against racial inequality,
在类似情况下遭到残忍谋杀，本应成为头条大新闻，但这些案件却几乎没有受到媒体的关注。许多社区成员认为这是因为受害者的肤色。1971年，华盛顿特区正处于种族动乱的状态。三年前的1968年4月，曾荣获诺贝尔和平奖的浸信会牧师兼民权活动家马丁·路德·金（Martin Luther King Jr.）牧师在田纳西州访问期间遇刺身亡，当时他正前往支持非裔美国公共环卫工人。作为反对种族不平等的杰出且极具影响力的倡导者，
Reverend King's murder triggered riots across the country, particularly in DC, where 70% of the population was African American. Despite being the majority population, people of color were subject to racial segregation, injustice, workplace discrimination, deficient education opportunities, and police brutality. Martin Luther King Jr.'s death sparked four days of violent protests, fires, and looting throughout DC, leaving 13 people dead and almost 1,000 businesses significantly damaged. As Washington DC's police force was predominantly white, the widespread distrust of law enforcement remained for many years that followed.
金牧师的遇害引发了全国各地的骚乱，尤其是在华盛顿特区，这里70%的人口都是非裔美国人。尽管占人口多数，但有色人种依然遭受着种族隔离、不公正待遇、职场歧视、教育机会匮乏以及警察暴力执法。马丁·路德·金的遇害在整个华盛顿特区引发了为期四天的暴力抗议、火灾和打砸抢劫，导致13人死亡，近1000家企业损毁严重。由于华盛顿特区警方以白人为主，因此在之后的多年里，公众对执法机构的广泛不信任感一直存在。
On Wednesday, July 21, Congress Heights residents called a press conference outside Carroll Spinks apartment building, where a crowd of 75 people protested the lack of police and media attention over the three murders. Calvin Rollark, editor and publisher of weekly newspaper The Washington Informer and president of the Washington Highland Civic Association, accused the police of failing to give equal treatment to crimes in the southeast, saying it took up to six hours for police to respond when called to their neighborhoods. Calvin stated,
7月21日星期三，国会高地居民在卡罗尔·斯平克斯的公寓楼外召开了新闻发布会，现场有75人聚集抗议警方和媒体对这三起谋杀案缺乏关注。《华盛顿知情人》（The Washington Informer）周报的编辑兼出版商、华盛顿高地公民协会（Washington Highland Civic Association）会长卡尔文·罗拉克（Calvin Rollark）指责警方未能对东南区的犯罪行为给予平等待遇，并称警察接到报警后赶到他们社区往往需要长达六个小时。卡尔文表示：
If they won't protect us, we'll have to protect ourselves, form vigilantes. He was also critical of the media's inadequate coverage of the murders, remarking, If it was a blue-eyed white girl from Silver Spring, her picture would have been all over page one. A concerned citizen who had helped organize the search for Carroll Spinks blamed city officials for failing to install proper street lighting in lower-income neighborhoods, stating, We're sick and tired of the deaths of our girls. We get no help from the police at all.
“如果他们不保护我们，我们就得保护自己，成立民间自卫队。”他还批评媒体对这些谋杀案的报道严重不足，评论道：“如果这是一个来自银泉（Silver Spring）的蓝眼睛白人女孩，她的照片早就铺满头版了。”一名曾协助组织搜寻卡罗尔·斯平克斯的关切市民指责市政府官员未能在低收入社区安装适当的路灯，他表示：“我们对女孩们的死亡已经感到厌烦和痛心了。我们根本得不到警察的任何帮助。”
Given the community felt overlooked, young local men were encouraged to keep an eye out for anyone suspicious and to arm themselves with rocks in case they needed to help Vandalf an attacker. Darlene Johnson's mother, Helen, said, I thought this was a nice neighborhood. We want protection out here. We're a bunch of forgotten people. In response to this criticism, law enforcement maintained that the number of vehicles and helicopters patrolling the area had been increased.
鉴于社区居民感到被忽视，当地的年轻男性被鼓励密切注意任何可疑人员，并在需要帮助制服袭击者时准备好石头防身。达勒尼亚·约翰逊的母亲海伦说：“我以为这是一个不错的社区。我们需要这里的保护。我们是一群被遗忘的人。”针对这些批评，执法部门坚称他们已经增加了在该地区巡逻的车辆和直升机数量。
They stated that there was no physical evidence to link the three murders, but announced that a seven-member task force had been formed to investigate the crimes. Less than a week later, on Tuesday, July 27, 10-year-old Brenda Crockett was spending the warm evening splashing in a fire hydrant on her street, 12th place in northwest Washington. At around 8 p.m., her mother, Rita, asked her to go to the store to grab a loaf of bread and some pet food. Rita told Brenda to take a companion with her, either her seven-year-old sister Bertha or a friend.
他们表示，没有实质性证据将这三起谋杀案联系起来，但宣布已成立一个由七名成员组成的特别工作组来调查这些犯罪行为。不到一周后的7月27日星期二，10岁的布伦达·克罗克特（Brenda Crockett）正在华盛顿西北区12街（12th place）她家门前温暖的傍晚中泼水玩消防栓。晚上8点左右，她的母亲丽塔（Rita）让她去商店买一条面包和一些宠物食品。丽塔叫布伦达带个同伴一起去，可以是她7岁的妹妹伯莎（Bertha）或者一个朋友。
Brenda set out on the five-block walk to the nearby Safeway Market, dressed in blue and white floral shorts and a matching top with pink rollers in her hair. When her daughter failed to reappear half an hour later, Rita realized that Brenda did not follow her instructions and had embarked on the errand alone. She conducted a frantic search of the local streets, but her child was nowhere to be seen. An hour and 20 minutes had passed since Brenda left when, at approximately 9.20 p.m., the phone rang at the Crockett home. Seven-year-old Bertha answered, hearing her older sister's voice on the other line, clearly
布伦达出发前往五个街区外的加标志（Safeway）超市，她身穿蓝白碎花短裤和配套上衣，头发上卷着粉红色的发卷。半小时后女儿还没有回来，丽塔这才意识到布伦达没有听从她的指示，而是独自一人跑去买东西了。她在当地的街道上疯狂搜寻，但根本不见孩子的踪影。距离布伦达离开已经过去了一个小时二十分钟，大约晚上9点20分，克罗克特家的电话铃响了。7岁的伯莎接了电话，听到了电话那头大姐的声音，显然在
sobbing. Brenda explained that a white man had picked her up, but he was now sending her home in a cab. She said she thought she was in Virginia, a neighboring state, before abruptly saying goodbye and hanging up the phone. Twenty-five minutes later, the phone rang for a second time. Rita's partner, Theodore, answered. It was Brenda again who was still crying.
泣不成声。布伦达解释说，一个白人男子绑架了她，但现在正让她坐出租车回家。她说她觉得自己好像在邻近的弗吉尼亚州，随后便突然说再见并挂断了电话。二十分钟后，电话第二次响起。丽塔的伴侣西奥多（Theodore）接了电话。又是布伦达打来的，她仍在哭泣。
Theodore asked if she knew whereabouts in Virginia she was, to which Brenda responded, A white man took me. I'm alone in a house with a white man. Theodore instructed her to put the man on the phone, telling her he could come and pick her up. Brenda then asked, did my mother see me? Unsure what she meant, Theodore repeated his request to speak to the man, but Brenda explained he was outside.
西奥多问她知不知道自己在弗吉尼亚州的什么地方，布伦达回答说：“一个白人男子把我抓走了。我独自和一个白人男子待在一栋房子里。”西奥多让把电话交给那个男人，告诉他自己可以去接她。接着布伦达问：“我妈妈看到我了吗？”西奥多不明白她是什么意思，便重复了自己要跟那个男人说话的要求，但布伦达解释说他在外面。
Theodore then heard heavy footsteps in the background, prompting Brenda to whisper quickly, well, I'll see you, before the line went dead. At 5.50am the following morning, the police received a phone call from a hitchhiker who had discovered the body of a young girl lying in full view on a grassy mount alongside the John Hanson Highway in the Maryland town of Chevrolet, near an underpass west of the Kennellworth Avenue exit. The body was confirmed to be that of Brenda Crockett. The 10-year-old was 9 miles from home, positioned to face up with her arms above her head.
随后西奥多听到背景音里传来沉重的脚步声，这让布伦达急忙低声说道：“好了，回头见”，接着电话那头就断线了。第二天早上5点50分，警方接到了一名搭车客的电话，他在马州切罗威（Chevrolet）的约翰·汉森高速公路（John Hanson Highway）旁、肯尼沃斯大道（Kennellworth Avenue）出口以西的一处地下通道附近，发现了一具年轻女孩的尸体，正大剌剌地躺在一处长满草的小土丘上。经证实，死者正是布伦达·克罗克特。这名10岁女孩离家9英里，被摆成仰面朝天、双臂举过头顶的姿势。
Some investigators believed she had been thrown from a vehicle. She had been sexually assaulted and strangled to death with a scarf knotted around her neck and was wearing the same outfit she had left her house in, but was barefoot. The similarities to the murders of Carol Spinks and Darlenea Johnson were clear, however, Brenda's body was found in Prince George's County, some 20 miles from where the other girl's bodies were discovered. During her harrowing phone calls home, Brenda stated her whereabouts as somewhere in Virginia. Investigators theorized that the killer had fed her misleading information and may have
一些调查人员认为她是被从车里扔出来的。她曾遭到性侵，并被一根系着结的围巾勒死，脖子上系着围巾，身上穿着离开家时的那套衣服，但赤着脚。这与卡罗尔·斯平克斯和达勒尼亚·约翰逊谋杀案的相似之处显而易见，然而，布伦达的尸体被发现在乔治王子县（Prince George's County），距离其他女孩尸体被发现的地方大约有20英里远。在令人心碎的回家电话中，布伦达说她身处弗吉尼亚州的某个地方。调查人员推测，凶手向她灌输了误导性信息，并可能
forced Brenda to make the calls to buy some time and throw off police. Her question in the second call as to whether her mother had seen her led to the possibility that Reethan knew her daughter's abductor, and he was checking to see if he had been seen with Brenda. Another possibility was that Brenda spotted her mother during her captivity, perhaps while Reethan was wondering the local streets looking for her. News of Brenda's murder spread, causing the usually vibrant streets of her former neighborhood to empty as children were kept inside.
强迫布伦达打电话以争取时间并误导警方。她在第二通电话中询问母亲是否看到过她，这引发了一种可能性，即丽塔认识女儿的绑架者，而凶手正在检查自己是否曾与布伦达一同被看到过。另一种可能性是布伦达在被囚禁期间看到了母亲，也许当时丽塔正在当地街头寻找她。关于布伦达遇害的消息传开后，她以前那个通常充满生气的社区街道变得空空荡荡，孩子们都被关在屋里。
One resident remarked, We usually have lots of gangs going on in the street, but nobody's been acting right today. I think everyone is disturbed. On Friday October 1, a little over two months after Brenda's murder, construction worker William Yates asked his 12 year old daughter, Nana Mosia, if she could go to the store to pick up some sugar, flour and paper plates. His wife, Nana Mosia's stepmother, had recently given birth, and William was heading to the
一位居民评论道：“平时街上有很多帮派活动，但今天谁都不正常。我觉得所有人都受到了惊扰。”10月1日星期五，在布伦达遇害两个多月后，建筑工人威廉·耶茨（William Yates）问他12岁的女儿娜娜·莫西亚（Nana Mosia），能不能去商店买点糖、面粉和纸盘子。他的妻子、娜娜·莫西亚的继母最近刚生了孩子，威廉正赶往
hospital to visit her and his newborn. He trusted Nana Mosia wholeheartedly. As the second eldest of his four children, she was mature and could be relied on. Dressed in brown shorts, a sweatshirt and white tennis shoes, Nana Mosia left her family's apartment building on Benning Road, southeast in Washington DC at approximately 7pm, and made her way towards the Safeway Market Store located at the end of her street. When William returned from the hospital, he noticed Nana Mosia wasn't home. After calls to friends and neighbors failed to locate her, William ran to the Safeway
医院去探望她和新生儿。他对娜娜·莫西亚百分之百地信任。作为四个孩子中的老二，她很成熟，是个靠得住的孩子。娜娜·莫西亚穿着棕色短裤、运动衫和白色网球鞋，于晚上7点左右离开了位于华盛顿特区东南区本宁路（Benning Road）的家庭公寓楼，朝她家街尽头的加标志超市走去。威廉从医院回来时，发现娜娜·莫西亚不在家。在打电话给朋友和邻居都未能找到她后，威廉跑到了加标志
Market, where staff confirmed she had arrived earlier and purchased the items on her grocery list. Less than three hours later, a hitchhiker was walking along Pennsylvania Avenue in Maryland, less than half a mile off the freeway, when they came across a grassy area holding the still warm body of Nana Mosia Yates. The 12-year-old was fully clothed, except for her white tennis shoes, which were missing. Nana Mosia's house key and $2.91 in loose change were scattered next to her body, along with a bag of sugar. She had been sexually assaulted and strangled with such force that her esophagus had been broken. There was a small scratch on her forehead and green fibers on her body.
超市，店员证实她之前确实来过，并买了购物单上的东西。不到三个小时后，一名搭车客正走在马里兰州的宾夕法尼亚大道（Pennsylvania Avenue）上，距离高速公路不到半英里，突然发现了一处草地，上面躺着娜娜·莫西亚·耶茨尚有余温的尸体。这名12岁的女孩衣着完整，唯独她那双白色网球鞋不见了。娜娜·莫西亚的家门钥匙和价值2.91美元的零钱散落在她的尸体旁，旁边还有一袋糖。她曾遭到性侵，并被残忍勒死，力道之大甚至导致她的食道断裂。她的额头上有道小划痕，身上则有绿色纤维。
A Safeway Market employee said that the morning after Nana Mosia had visited the store, they found a bag of flour and a pack of paper plates outside, near the front entrance. Police suspected Nana Mosia had likely been abducted as soon as she had left the store, causing her to drop two of her grocery items. A local resident recalled seeing the young girl getting into a blue Volkswagen with a Maryland license plate on the night of her disappearance. Police tracked down and seized 25 vehicles matching this description, but found no evidence to suggest any of the owners had been involved in the crime. From the outset, detectives admitted there were similarities between Nana Mosia's death
加标志超市的一名员工说，在娜娜·莫西亚光顾超市的第二天早上，他们在前门附近的外面发现了一袋面粉和一包纸盘子。警方推测，娜娜·莫西亚很可能一离开超市就遭到了绑架，导致她丢下了两件杂货。一位当地居民回忆说，在失踪当晚曾看到这个年轻女孩上了一辆挂着马里兰州车牌的蓝色大众汽车。警方追踪并扣押了25辆符合这一描述的车辆，但没有发现任何证据表明这些车主与此案有关。从一开始，侦探们就承认娜娜·莫西亚的死与
and the other four unsolved murders, and increased their task force to include 40 investigators. They came from various divisions, including the Washington Metropolitan, Prince George's County and Montgomery County Police Departments, the Maryland State Police, and the FBI. The crimes finally started receiving widespread media coverage, with the press naming the unknown killer, the Freeway Phantom. 18-year-old Brenda Woodard had recently moved out of the home she shared with her parents and five siblings on Maryland Avenue, northeast in D.C. After some recent disputes with her parents, Brenda relocated to a friend's place across the courtyard. The move was only temporary,
其他四起未破谋杀案存在相似之处，并将他们的特别工作组规模扩大到包括40名调查人员。他们来自不同的部门，包括华盛顿大都会警察局、乔治王子县和蒙哥马利县警察局、马里兰州警察局以及联邦调查局（FBI）。这些案件终于开始受到广泛的媒体关注，媒体将这个未知的杀手称为“高速公路幽灵”（Freeway Phantom）。18岁的布伦达·伍达德（Brenda Woodard）最近刚搬出了她与父母以及五个兄弟姐妹位于特区东北区马里兰大道（Maryland Avenue）的家。由于最近与父母发生了一些争执，布伦达搬到了庭院对面朋友的住处。这次搬家只是暂时的，
and she stayed in regular contact with her family. On the night she found out about Nana Mosia Yates's murder, Brenda called her mother to warn her to keep an extra close eye on her younger sisters. On the evening of Monday, November 15, Brenda visited her family, requesting a ride to Cardozo High School, where she was attending night classes to obtain typing and shorthand skills. Throughout the summer, she had worked as a counselor for the Department of Recreation and was seeking more stable employment. Her father agreed to drop her off, giving her a kiss goodbye and telling her to give him a call if she couldn't find a lift home, in which case he or one of her younger sisters would come and pick her up. Brenda attended class, and afterwards
她与家人保持着经常的联系。在得知娜娜·莫西亚·耶茨遇害消息的那天晚上，布伦达打电话给母亲，警告她要格外密切地照看好年幼的妹妹们。11月15日星期一傍晚，布伦达探望了家人，要求搭车去卡多佐高中（Cardozo High School），她当时正在那里上夜校以学习打字和速记技能。整个夏天，她一直在娱乐部担任辅导员，并一直在寻找更稳定的工作。她的父亲答应送她，给了她一个吻作为告别，并告诉她如果找不到车回家就给他打电话，那样的话他和她的小妹妹之一就会开车去接她。布伦达去上课了，课后
joined a classmate for a late dinner at a nearby restaurant, Ben's Chili Bowl. The pair decided to catch the bus home together, and at 10.25pm, they boarded a bus on the corner of 8th and 8th Street, northeast. As it didn't travel directly to Brenda's neighborhood, she had to switch buses halfway through the journey. Just before 11pm, she said goodbye to her friend and disembarked to wait at the nearby stop for the line that would take her back home to Maryland Avenue. The following morning, rush hour traffic along the Maryland Route 202 Highway was at a standstill. Mary Woodard had been waiting over an hour for a bus to attend a doctor's appointment, when a passing security guard told her there had been a delay as traffic was held up due to the
和一名同学去附近的一家餐馆——本奇利碗（Ben's Chili Bowl）吃了一顿深夜晚餐。两人决定一起坐公交车回家，晚上10点25分，他们在东北区第八街交界处上了一辆公交车。由于该车不直达布伦达的社区，她不得不在中途换乘公交车。快到晚上11点时，她向朋友道了别，下车在附近的车站等候能带她回马里兰大道家中的那趟车。第二天早晨，马里兰202号公路沿线的早高峰交通陷入瘫痪。玛丽·伍达德（Mary Woodard）为了去看医生已经等了一个多小时的车，这时一名路过的保安告诉她，由于202号公路附近发现了一具男尸导致交通拥堵，公交车延误了。
discovery of a man's body off Route 202. As Mary began walking to a different bus stop, she saw crowds of police, press, and onlookers gathered on the other side of the road, near the shoulder of the highway. A little further on, she noticed a wig lying in the middle of the road, and recognized it as similar to one that belonged to her 18-year-old daughter, Brenda. Unable to get the wig out of her mind, Mary returned home from her doctor's appointment just before midday to find her phone ringing off the hook. But turned out, the body found on Highway 202 hadn't been a man after all, but a young woman. Mary received a call from her daughter's housemate, informing her that Brenda hadn't returned home after her classes the night
正当玛丽走向另一个公交车站时，她看到路的另一侧、高速公路路肩附近聚集了成群的警察、媒体和旁观者。再往前走一点，她注意到马路中间躺着一顶假发，并认出它和她18岁的女儿布伦达的一顶假发很像。脑海中一直挥之不去那顶假发的影子，玛丽在接近中午时分从医生的预约中赶回家，却发现家里的电话铃响个不停。原来，在202号公路发现的尸体根本不是什么男性，而是一名年轻女性。玛丽接到了女儿室友的电话，被告知布伦达昨晚下课后并没有回家。
before. A panicked stricken Mary called the police to report her daughter missing, and they arrived to the Woodard house to present photographs of the body found on the grassy embankment along Highway 202. It was Brenda Woodard. At 5am earlier that morning, a police officer was conducting his routine patrol on hospital drive in Chevrolet when he sighted Brenda's body. She was fully clothed, wearing a black and white checkered skirt, a black turtleneck sweater which was inside out, a pair of black boots, and a maroon velvet coat that had been draped over her body. She had been sexually assaulted, strangled, and stabbed in the chest six times, the deep wound to her breastbone proving fatal. A small bone in her neck was broken due to
惊慌失措的玛丽打电话给警察报案称女儿失踪，警察赶到伍达德家，出示了在高速公路旁草坡上发现的尸体照片。那正是布伦达·伍达德。当天清晨5点，一名警员在舍维尔（Chevrolet）的医院大道（hospital drive）上例行巡逻时，发现了布伦达的尸体。她衣着完整，穿着一件黑白格子裙、一件里外穿反的黑色高领毛衣、一双黑色靴子，身上还披着一件栗色天鹅绒大衣。她曾遭到性侵、勒颈，胸部还被刺了六刀，胸骨上的致命伤夺去了她的生命。由于
strangulation, and defensive wounds indicated she had put up a fight. Two human hairs were found on her body, one from a Caucasian person and one from an African American person. As this was before the implementation of DNA testing, the hairs were not deemed to be vital evidence, as there was no way for investigators to know whether they had come from the killer, an officer at the scene, or someone else Brenda had bumped into prior to her attack. Inside the pocket of her coat was a piece of white notebook paper with a handwritten message that read, this is tantamount to my insensitivity to people, especially women. I will admit the others when you catch me if you can. The note was signed, the freeway phantom.
勒颈导致她颈部的一块小骨头断裂，防卫伤表明她曾进行过反抗。她的尸体上发现了两根人类毛发，一根来自白人，另一根来自非裔美国人。由于当时尚未实施DNA检测，这两根毛发并未被视为关键证据，因为调查人员无法确定它们是来自凶手、现场的警员，还是布伦达在遇袭前偶然碰到的其他人。在大衣口袋里有一张白色的笔记本纸，上面有手写的留言，写着：“这相当于我对人们尤其是女性的麻木不仁。你们抓到我时我会承认其他的。”纸条的署名是“高速公路幽灵”。
The paper had been cut from Brenda's school notebook and FBI handwriting experts ascertained it was penned by Brenda herself. It was believed the killer forced her to write the note as he dictated the message. However, as the writing was neat and showed no signs of fear or panic, some investigators theorized that Brenda may have known her killer and he had asked her to write the note under the guise of being a joke before launching his attack. If the killer was unknown to Brenda, police had no explanation for why the note was written the way it was. On Wednesday November 17, the day after Brenda Woodard's body was found, a press conference was held wherein a special phone tip line was announced. Washington Metropolitan
这张纸是从布伦达的学校笔记本上撕下来的，联邦调查局的笔迹专家证实这确实是布伦达本人的笔迹。据信是凶手在口授信息的同时强迫她写下这张纸条。然而，由于字迹工整且没有显示出恐惧或惊慌的迹象，一些调查人员推测布伦达可能认识凶手，凶手是在假装开玩笑的幌子下要求她写下这张纸条，随后便发动了袭击。如果布伦达并不认识凶手，警方就无法解释这张纸条为何会写成这样。11月17日星期三，即布伦达·伍达德的尸体被发现的第二天，举行了一场新闻发布会，会上公布了一条专门的电话举报热线。华盛顿大都会
Police Inspector Maylan Pitts had admitted that while it was impossible to ignore the similarities between the six murders, he was unable to confirm for certain whether they were connected. He acknowledged the pattern that had emerged in which each of the victims had been young black females who were residents of the Washington DC area and had been killed in a similar manner before being left near the side of a busy highway. A majority of the girls had also been left without their shoes. Although there was a significant age gap between the youngest victim, 10-year-old Brenda Crockett and the eldest, 18-year-old Brenda Woodard, the latter appeared youthful and could have been mistaken for being younger. Inspector Pitts said investigators
警察局督察梅兰·皮茨（Maylan Pitts）承认，虽然不可能忽视这六起谋杀案之间的相似之处，但他无法完全确认它们是否有关联。他承认出现了一种模式：每位受害者都是居住在华盛顿特区地区的年轻黑人女性，且都以类似的方式遇害，随后被抛弃在一条繁忙的高速公路旁。大多数女孩被发现时鞋子都不翼而飞。尽管年纪最小的受害者10岁的布伦达·克罗克特与年纪最大的18岁的布伦达·伍达德之间存在显著的年龄差距，但后者看起来很年轻，很容易被误认为是更小的孩子。皮茨督察表示，调查人员
were keeping an open mind about the possibility that separate killers were responsible, but were staging their crimes to fit the circumstances of the other cases to detract attention from themselves. In anticipation of people coming forward to make false confessions, the police withheld details about the note found in Brenda Woodard's pocket, ensuring only the killer would know this information. He clarified that there were no direct links between any of the victims and that none of the girls were known to one another. He said that the police were working hard to solve the murders, but had no leads and were uncertain how many perpetrators were involved. The police strongly believed that the victims had been either lured or forced into the perpetrator's
对存在不同凶手犯案、但刻意模仿其他案件情况以转移注意力的可能性持开放态度。为了防范有人出面作虚假供述，警方隐去了在布伦达·伍达德口袋中发现的纸条的细节，以确保只有凶手本人才知道这些信息。他澄清说，受害者之间没有任何直接联系，女孩们也互不相识。他说警方正在全力破案，但目前尚无头破案线索，也不确定涉案凶手究竟有几人。警方坚信，受害者是被诱骗或强行拉进凶手的
vehicle and that there may have been others who had escaped similar attempts. Anyone who had refused the offer of a lift or had successfully fought off someone who tried to force them into a car was encouraged to come forward. Inspector Pitts quote, Somewhere in this community is an individual who probably has a clue that will help solve this case. Somebody knows a sex deviant or a child molester. Somebody knows something. Mayor Walter Washington also made an appearance to pledge that the task force had the full support of the city's government resources. Maryland Senator Charles Mathias made a plea to the parents of young girls throughout DC's metropolitan area to take extra precautions until the killer was
汽车里的，并且可能还有其他人曾从类似企图（绑架）中逃脱。任何拒绝搭车邀请或成功击退试图将他们强行拉入车内的人都被鼓励站出来提供线索。皮茨督察原话引用：“在这个社区的某处，藏着一个人，他可能掌握着有助于破案的线索。有人认识性变态者，或者儿童猥亵犯。有人知道些什么。”市长沃尔特·华盛顿（Walter Washington）也现身表态，承诺特别工作组将获得市政府资源的全力支持。马里兰州参议员查尔斯·马蒂亚斯（Charles Mathias）呼吁整个华盛顿特区大都会地区的年轻女孩父母采取额外防范措施，直到凶手被
apprehended. After the press conference roadblocks were set up around the highway exit near where Brenda Woodard's body was found. Peak hour traffic was stalled as police questioned motorists, but little of interest was uncovered. Investigators turned their focus to the St. Elizabeth Hospital, a federally operated mental health facility that sat alongside the Suitland Parkway, right near where the bodies of Carol Spinks and Darlenea Johnson had been found. In recent times, more than 30 court-ordered maximum security patients had escaped from the institution. The backgrounds of the escapees who had been institutionalized for committing serious sexual offenses after being found not guilty due to reasons of insanity were looked into,
缉拿归案。新闻发布会结束后，警方在发现布伦达·伍达德尸体附近的高速公路出口周围设置了路障。由于警察盘问司机，高峰时段的交通陷入停滞，但几乎没有查获任何有价值的线索。调查人员将焦点转向了伊丽莎白圣公会医院，这是一所联邦运营的精神健康机构，位于苏特兰公园大道旁，正好在发现卡罗尔·斯平克斯和达勒尼亚·约翰逊尸体的地方附近。最近一段时间，已有30多名经法院下令收治的最高安全级别患者从该机构逃脱。警方对这些逃犯的背景进行了调查，他们此前因被判无罪但精神失常而被收容以治疗重罪性犯罪，
but after tracking them down, all were ruled out of the investigation and returned to the facility. Dr. Sheldon Freud, a psychologist who worked with the Prince George's County Police Department, noticed another detail in the Freeway Phantom's pattern. Four out of the six victims shared the same middle name, Denise. Dr. Freud believed the killer was deliberately seeking out young girls associated with the name Denise and warned, I would think that any girl with the name Denise would be particularly careful. Random killing is not very common. Assuming that this is one man, we might suppose that he has some hostile association with the name Denise or even the letter D. A doctor who worked in the maximum security wing at the St. Elizabeth Hospital agreed it was
但在追踪他们之后，所有人都被排除在调查之外，并被送回了该机构。谢尔顿·弗洛伊德博士（Dr. Sheldon Freud）是一名与乔治王子县警察局合作的心理学家，他注意到了“高速公路幽灵”作案模式中的另一个细节。六名受害者中有四人拥有相同的中间名——丹尼斯（Denise）。弗洛伊德博士认为凶手是在刻意寻找名字中带有“丹尼斯”的年轻女孩，并警告说：“我认为任何名叫丹尼斯的女孩都应该格外小心。随机杀人并不常见。假设这是一名男子所为，我们可能会推测他对‘丹尼斯’这个名字甚至字母‘D’有着某种敌对的联想。”伊丽莎白圣公会医院最高安全级别病区的一名医生也认同
possible that the killer had a fixation on the name. Yet, Denise was an incredibly common name at the time, and if it proved true, it didn't explain why Brenda Crockett and Nana Mosier Yates were targeted, as they had no association with the name. Police Inspector Maylan Pitts dismissed the theory, stating that the Denise connection was nothing more than sheer coincidence. Hundreds of calls were placed to the Task Force Hotline, with the team of six operators quickly doubling to 12 to deal with the influx of tip-offs. Within just four days, 4,000 calls had come through from the public. Most were from female residents of Southeast D.C., who reported being offered rides from strange men and witnessing suspicious cars cruising the area, with the male drivers and
凶手可能对这个名字有执念。然而，在当时“丹尼斯”是一个非常普遍的名字，如果这一推测属实，它就无法解释为什么布伦达·克罗克特和娜娜·莫西亚·耶茨会成为目标，因为她们与这个名字毫无关联。警察督察梅兰·皮茨驳斥了这一理论，称“丹尼斯”的联系纯属巧合。成百上千通电话打进了工作组热线，接线员团队迅速从6人翻倍至12人，以应对大量涌入的线索。短短四天内，公众就打进去了4000通电话。其中大部分来自华盛顿特区东南区的女性居民，她们报告称遭到陌生男子的搭车搭讪，并目击可疑车辆在区内巡游，男司机和
passengers sometimes hurling out insults. Multiple theories arose around the identity of the killer, including that he was a taxi driver or a teacher or employee within the public school system who had access to school records, enabling him to select victims with the middle name of Denise. One call made to the tip line was from a young girl with a high-pitched, squeaky voice, who simply said, my father is the phantom. When the operator asked for her father's name, the girl disconnected the call. During another call, a voice announced, I've got some information for you. When you find the phantom, you'll be surprised, because the phantom wears a policeman's uniform. With no concrete evidence, solid leads or prime suspects, high-level government officials
乘客有时会恶语相向。围绕凶手的身份出现了多种理论，包括他是一名出租车司机，或者是能够接触到学校记录的公立学校系统内的老师或员工，这使他能够挑选中间名叫丹尼斯的受害者。打到热线的一通电话来自一个声音尖锐高亢的小女孩，她简单地说：“我父亲就是那个幽灵。”当接线员追问她父亲的名字时，女孩挂断了电话。在另一通电话中，一个声音宣称：“我有些信息要告诉你。当你找到那个幽灵时，你会大吃一惊的，因为那个幽灵穿着警察制服。”由于缺乏具体的证据、可靠的线索或主要嫌疑人，白宫的
from the White House expressed their concern over the unsolved murders and instructed the Justice Department to provide an extra level of support to aid the investigation. The increase in media attention intensified fear across the city, with one resident remarking, I feel like I'm going to carry me a gun every damn place I go, and to the first one that looks at me wrong is going to get the wrong end of the deal. Other members of the community took a more peaceful yet unconventional approach. A religious organization called the Christian Services Corporation launched radio and television appeals pleading to the killer to turn himself in, so that they could offer him their assistance. The group received support and guidance from Dr
高级政府官员对这些未破谋杀案表示担忧，并指示司法部提供额外层面的支持以协助调查。媒体关注度的增加加剧了全城的恐惧，一位居民评论道：“我觉得我他妈的去哪儿都得带把枪，谁要是敢斜眼看我一眼，谁就要倒大霉。”社区的其他成员则采取了更为和平但不同寻常的方法。一个名为“基督教服务公司”（Christian Services Corporation）的宗教组织在电台和电视台发起呼吁，恳求凶手自首，以便他们能向他提供帮助。该集团得到了博士的支持和指导
Sheldon Freud, the psychologist behind the Denise theory, who voiced his belief that the killer could not control his impulses, and that the atmosphere of panic created by the freeway phantom nickname was likely only feeding his psychosis. Quote, This is not a horror movie. We are dealing with a human being who probably cannot control himself. He should be told that if he'll give himself up, he'll get treatment. Instead of saying to the police, you catch the guy. People are beginning to realize the community is the first echelon. The police come in when the community fails. The change in strategy presented by the Christian Services Corporation led to a public service announcement appearing in newspapers and being broadcast on the radio. Written by an
谢尔顿·弗洛伊德是“丹尼斯理论”背后的心理学家，他表达了自己的看法，认为凶手无法控制自己的冲动，“高速公路幽灵”这个绰号所制造的恐慌气氛可能只会助长他的精神病。他原话说道：“这不是恐怖电影。我们面对的是一个可能无法控制自己的人。应该告诉他，如果他自首，他会得到治疗。”而不是对警察说：“你们去抓这个人。”人们开始意识到，社区是第一道防线。社区失效时，警察才会介入。基督教服务联合会提出的战略转变促使了一则公共服务公告在报纸上刊登并在电台广播。这则公告由一名
anonymous citizen, the message read, This is an appeal to the person or persons responsible for the deaths of the young girls. Please call this number 4629415. This is a pay phone and it is not taped and you'll hear my voice only. Here's why I'm asking you to call right now. I'm more concerned about you. You probably feel the whole world is after you. You may be scared. You may be just plain tired. If you are, there is someone you can turn to without fear. Believed to be the first public service announcement of its kind, within one hour of its broadcast, eight calls were placed to the pay phone. Three callers just breathed heavily into the receiver, purposely holding up the line. The other five, one of whom was a woman named Denise
匿名市民撰写，内容如下：“这是对杀害年轻女孩的责任人或责任人的呼吁。请拨打这个电话：4629415。这是一个公用电话，没有被录音，你只会听到我的声音。以下是我现在请求你打电话的原因。我更关心你。你可能觉得全世界都在追捕你。你可能会害怕。你可能只是单纯觉得累。如果是这样，你可以毫无恐惧地向某人求助。”据信这是同类广播中的第一则公共服务公告，在其广播后的一小时内，该公用电话接到了八个电话。三个打电话的人只是对着听筒重重地喘气，故意占线。另外五个——其中之一是一名名叫丹尼斯
near hysterical with worry, simply wanted to discuss their theories about the killer. The Freeway Phantom himself remained silent. By late November, the Freeway Phantom case had reached full media saturation. The National Fraternal Order of Police Detectives and Special Police Association posted a $50 reward for information leading to an arrest and conviction of the person or persons responsible. A spokesperson for the group said they hoped their actions would inspire others to contribute to the reward fund. Their appeal was successful, prompting contributions to come in from Washington's Evening Star newspaper, local radio station WUST and members of the local warehouse union.
的妇女，她焦急得近乎歇斯底里——只是想讨论他们对凶手的种种推测。“高速公路幽灵”本人则保持沉默。到了11月下旬，“高速公路幽灵”一案的媒体关注度已趋于饱和。全国警察侦探兄弟会和特种警察协会悬赏5万元，征集能促成逮捕和定罪涉案责任人或多人的线索。该组织的一名发言人表示，他们希望自己的行动能激励其他人为悬赏基金做出贡献。他们的呼吁取得了成功，促使华盛顿的《晚星报》、当地电台WUST以及当地仓库工会成员纷纷捐款。
Soon, the reward pool reached a total of $9,000. In early December, police released a series of coloured photographs of a mannequin dressed in the same clothes and hairstyle Brenda Woodard was sporting on the night of her abduction. The mannequin also held a stack of four school books that matched ones Brenda was carrying. The FBI had achieved success with this technique in the past, crediting their last mannequin display for the arrest and conviction of a criminal who kidnapped and murdered a seven-year-old child. Yet, the effort proved fruitless in Brenda's case. One of the strongest leads was a late model red Chevrolet Chevelle with chrome strips that had
不久，悬赏金总额达到了9000美元。12月初，警方公布了一系列彩色照片，照片上是一个人体模特，穿着布伦达·伍德拉德在被绑架当晚所穿的同款衣服，梳着同样的髮型。这个人体模特还拿着一叠四本学校课本，与布伦达当时携带的书籍完全相符。联邦调查局过去使用这种技术取得过成功，他们将上一次的人体模特展示归功于对一名绑架并谋杀七岁儿童的罪犯的逮捕和定罪。然而，在布伦达的案子中，这一努力被证明是徒劳的。最有力的一条线索是一辆带有镀铬条纹的后期型红色的雪佛兰切维尔轿车，它曾
been seen near where Brenda's body was found. Police appealed to the public to be on the lookout for vehicles that matched this description, which prompted an unlikely response from a group of Vietnam war veterans who formed an organisation titled the Veterans Protective League. Dressed in their service uniforms, the men used private vehicles to patrol several of Washington's major freeways 24 hours a day on the lookout for the red Chevrolet Chevelle. When the police found out about the vigilante group, they admitted they needed all the help they could get, but advised the public to leave the dangerous work to the authorities. The pressure was on for the task force to make an arrest, but in addition to the lack of evidence
被人看到停在发现布伦达尸体的地方附近。警方呼吁公众留意符合这一描述的车辆，这引起了一群越南战争退伍军人的意料之外的响应，他们成立了一个名为“退伍军人保护联盟”的组织。这些男子身穿制服，驾驶私家车在华盛顿几条主要高速公路上实行24小时巡逻，寻找那辆红色的雪佛兰切维尔。当警方得知这个民间治安维持团体时，他们承认他们需要能得到的所有帮助，但建议公众把这项危险的工作留给有关当局。专案组面临着必须破案的巨大压力，但除了缺乏证据
highlighting a suspect, the Freeway Phantom case was just one of many ongoing murder investigations plaguing the DC area. In the previous 11 months, 250 murders had occurred within the district, 36 of which remained unsolved. Calls to the hotline slowed, and soon the phones fell completely silent. Anticipations remained high that the killer would strike again, but the months began to pass without incident. The people of Washington wondered if the Freeway Phantom's killing spree had come to an end and deliberated over what prompted him to stop. Metropolitan Police Inspector Maylan Pitz considered the possibilities, telling the public, quote, The suspect could have been attached to a military base and been transferred. He could have been
来锁定嫌疑人之外，“高速公路幽灵”案只是困扰特区地区的众多未破谋杀案之一。在过去的11个月里，该地区发生了250起谋杀案，其中36起至今未破。热线电话开始减少，不久电话便彻底沉寂下来。人们依然高度期待凶手会再次作案，但几个月过去了，却风平浪静。华盛顿的人们开始纳闷，“高速公路幽灵”的狂热杀戮是否已经结束，并揣测是什么原因促使他停手的。华盛顿特区大都会警察局督察梅兰·皮茨考虑了各种可能性，他对公众说：“嫌疑人可能隶属于某个军事基地并已被调动。他可能
arrested on some other charge and incarcerated without our knowing it, or he could have been committed to an institution. By September 1972, almost a year and a half had passed since the beginning of the Freeway Phantom's crime spree. It had been 10 months since the body of the body of Brenda Woodard had been discovered, and the case had slipped from the headlines, replaced by the political Watergate scandal, which diverted the FBI's attention from the unsolved murders. Life slowly returned to normal for the residents of Southeast DC. 17-year-old Diane Williams lived with her parents and five younger siblings on Halley Terrace, Southeast, in Congress Heights, just off the exit of the Interstate 295 Highway.
因其他罪行被捕并在我们不知情的情况下被收监，或者他可能被送进了精神病院。”到1972年9月，“高速公路幽灵”开始作案已经过去了一年半左右。距离布伦达·伍德拉德的尸体被发现已经过去了10个月，这个案子也从头条新闻中淡出，取而代之的是水门事件政治丑闻，这分散了联邦调查局对未破谋杀案的注意力。东南特区居民的生活慢慢恢复了平静。17岁的黛安·威廉姆斯与父母和五个年幼的弟妹住在国会高地的东南海利露台，紧邻295号州际公路的出口。
Her summer vacation was spent working for the Department of Recreation, and by Tuesday, September 5, the program had come to an end, so Diane and her siblings were preparing to return to school. That morning, Diane visited the Recreation Center to collect her final paycheck, and to then went shopping with her family to pick out paint colors for a staircase they were redecorating. The group returned home just after midday, and Diane took an afternoon nap, arising several hours later to prepare dinner. As they sat down to wait, Diane's boyfriend, James, called the house. He had purchased some new records and invited Diane over to listen to them together. Her parents agreed, on the condition that she returned home no later than 10.30pm.
她的暑假是在娱乐部工作度过的，到9月5日星期二，该计划已经结束，因此黛安和她的兄弟姐妹们正准备返回学校。那天早上，黛安去了娱乐中心领取她的最后一笔薪水，随后和家人去购物，为他们正在重新装修的楼梯挑选油漆颜色。一行人在中午刚过后回到家中，黛安睡了个午觉，几个小时后醒来准备晚饭。正当他们坐下来等待时，黛安的男友詹姆斯打来电话。他买了一些新唱片，邀请黛安过去一起听。她的父母同意了，条件是她必须在晚上10点半之前回家。
Diane borrowed some change from her mother for the bus fare and set out on her journey. At 10.30pm, Diane's mother Margaret informed her husband to Leon that their daughter had missed curfew. Leon told her not to worry, certain that Diane had just gotten caught up and would be home any minute. He left for work as Margaret kept due to full watch of the clock. 11.00pm came and went, and there was still no sign of Diane. Margaret called James and was informed Diane had since left her boyfriend's house. James had escorted her to the bus stop on the corner of Martin Luther King Road and Howard Avenue over an hour ago, waiting until she was safely on board. Not wanting to jump to any conclusions,
黛安向母亲借了零钱作为车费，踏上了行程。晚上10点30分，黛安的母亲玛格丽特告诉丈夫里昂，他们的女儿已经过了门禁时间。里昂告诉她不用担心，确信黛安只是被什么事耽搁了，随时都会回家。他出门去上班，而玛格丽特则紧盯着时钟。晚上11点到了又过去，依然不见黛安的踪影。玛格丽特打电话给詹姆斯，被告知黛安已经离开了她男友的家。一个多小时前，詹姆斯曾护送她到马丁·路德·金路和霍华德大道转角处的公交车站，一直等到她安全上车。不想妄下结论，
Margaret decided not to alert her husband of the situation unfolding, and instead stayed up waiting for Diane. 12.00pm The next morning, Leon was driving home from work when he saw a truck pulled to the side of the Interstate 295 Highway with a hand full of men gathered around. He didn't think much of it and arrived home, where he learned that his daughter was still missing. He called the police to notify them of Diane's disappearance, describing her outfit, blue jeans with a yellow blouse. 13.00pm Across the border in Maryland, the Prince George's County Police Department
玛格丽特决定不惊动正在工作的丈夫，而是留下来等黛安。凌晨12点。第二天早上，里昂开车回家时，看到一堆人围着一辆停在295号州际公路路边的卡车。他没多想便回到了家，并在那里得知女儿依然失踪。他打电话给警察局报告黛安失踪，描述了她的穿着：蓝色牛仔裤搭配黄色上衣。下午1点。在马里兰州边界的另一侧，乔治王子县警察局
had just received reports of a body of a young woman found on a grassy incline eight feet from the edge of the Interstate 295, roughly 200 yards south from the Washington state line. A truck driver had been passing through the area when he noticed the figure and pulled over to investigate, finding the woman lying face down in the grass, fully clothed in jeans and a yellow top, but barefoot, with $1.26 in her pocket. She had been manually strangled and had a small bruise inside her left arm. A foreign hair was also found inside her mouth. As reports of the grim discovery circulated, the Washington Metropolitan Police contacted
刚刚接到报告，称在距离295号州际公路边缘8英尺远的草坡上发现了一具年轻女性的尸体，该地点大约在华盛顿州界以南200码处。一名卡车司机经过该地区时注意到了这个身影，于是停车查看，发现这名女子面朝下趴在草地上，穿着牛仔裤和黄色上衣但赤脚，口袋里有1.26美元。她曾被人为勒死，左臂内侧有一处小淤青。她的嘴里还发现了一根异国的毛发。随着这一骇人发现的消息传开，华盛顿大都会警察局联系了
the Prince George's County Police, believing the victim might be 17-year-old Diane Williams. Leon and Margaret viewed the body at the morgue, positively identifying the deceased as their daughter. As Diane's clothing was damp, the medical examiner deduced she had been left on the embankment overnight and estimated her time of death to be at least nine hours before she was found. If this was accurate, it meant Diane was killed not long after saying goodbye to her boyfriend. The five other Williams children were at home watching television when a news report flashed on screen detailing that Diane had been killed. Their neighbors heard screams and loud crashing noises as the children learned that their older sister was never coming home.
乔治王子县警察局，认为受害者可能是17岁的黛安·威廉姆斯。里昂和玛格丽特在太平间查看了尸体，确切辨认出死者就是他们的女儿。由于黛安的衣服是潮湿的，法医推断她被弃置在路堤上过夜，并估计她的死亡时间至少在她被发现前九小时。如果这个推断准确，那就意味着黛安在跟男友道别后不久就被杀害了。威廉姆斯家的另外五个孩子当时正在家里看电视，这时屏幕上闪过一则新闻报道，详述了黛安被杀的消息。邻居们听到孩子们得知大姐再也回不了家时发出的尖叫声和巨大的撞击声。
Margaret Williams later remarked, No one who has ever lost a child in such a manner as I could ever know what it is like. They think they know. You try to live, but really, you are living on the surface. The inside is dead. Bus driver Warren Williams had driven the same route five nights a week for the past two months. At approximately 11.21 p.m. on September 5, he recalled Diane Williams board his bus at the Martin Luther King Avenue stop near Howard Road. He distinctly remembered Diane as it was unusual for a young girl to be riding the bus alone late at night. At the time, there were roughly 20 other passengers on the bus, most of whom were men. He was certain that she, along with at least
玛格丽特·威廉姆斯后来感叹道：“任何像我这样失去过孩子的人都绝不会知道那是一种什么感觉。他们以为自己懂。你试着生活，但实际上，你只是在表面上活着。内心已经死了。”公交车司机沃伦·威廉姆斯在过去两个月中，每周有五个晚上都驾驶同一条路线。9月5日晚上11点21分左右，他回忆起黛安·威廉姆斯在霍华德路附近的马丁·路德·金大道车站上了他的车。他对黛安印象深刻，因为一个年轻女孩深夜独自乘车并不常见。当时，车上大约有其他20名乘客，其中大部分是男性。他确信她和至少
three other passengers, disembarked at the Martin Luther King Avenue and South Capitol Street intersection at around 11.50 p.m. Warren took no note of the other passengers as he had no reason to be suspicious. If his recollections were accurate, the only way for Diane to reach her home, a block and a half away on Halley Terrace, would have been to cross through a parking lot along a poorly lit street. Warren's story was bolstered by several of Diane's neighbors who heard screaming at around midnight on September 5. Two of Diane's sisters and two other teenage girls recalled an incident three weeks earlier wherein a man in a yellow car exposed himself to the group as they were out on the street. Believing this incident may be related,
另外三名乘客在晚上11点50分左右，在马丁·路德·金大道和南国会街交叉口下车。沃伦没有注意到其他乘客，因为他没有理由产生怀疑。如果他的回忆准确，黛安要回到位于海利露台、距离一个半街区远的家，唯一的办法就是穿过海利露台沿街一处光线昏暗的停车场。黛安几位邻居的证词印证了沃伦的说法，他们听到9月5日午夜左右传出了尖叫声。黛安的两个妹妹和其他两个十几岁的女孩回忆起三周前发生的一起事件：当时一个开着黄车的男子在街上对这群人露出下体。认为这一事件可能有关联，
the girls worked with a police sketch artist to create an image of the flasher, described as being of Mexican or Indian heritage. Three days after Diane's murder, a police spokesperson confirmed they were now treating the case as part of the Freeway Phantom investigation, stating that the teenager had likely been abducted after getting off the bus. They had conducted hundreds of interviews and were following up several leads, but were still no closer to identifying a prime suspect or making an arrest. Meanwhile, the Williams family received prank phone calls at all hours of the day and night. Some callers would ring and ask to speak to Diane before hanging up,
女孩们与警察肖像画师合作，绘制了这名露阴癖者的画像，据描述他具有墨西哥或印第安血统。在黛安被谋杀三天后，警方发言人证实，他们现在正将此案作为“高速公路幽灵”调查的一部分来处理，并表示这名少女很可能是下车后被绑架的。他们进行了数百次走访，并正在跟进几条线索，但仍未更接近于确定主要嫌疑人或实施逮捕。与此同时，威廉姆斯一家在白天和黑夜的各个时段都接到恶作剧电话。一些来电者会打通电话后要求找黛安说话，然后挂断，
while others unleashed a string of obscenities. One call came through at two in the morning with the caller declaring in a sinister voice, ''I killed your daughter.'' Yet they were also inundated with messages of support. Jennifer Woodard, the 16-year-old sister of Freeway Phantom victim Brenda Woodard, reached out to the Williams family with a letter expressing her greatest sympathies and mutual struggles. She wrote, ''I know that all the sympathy cards and notes of condolence in the world cannot erase away any portion of the pain that you must feel at this moment.
而另一些则爆发出连串的脏话。凌晨两点曾打来过一个电话，来电者用阴森的声音宣称：“我杀了你女儿。”然而，他们也收到了源源不断的声援信息。“高速公路幽灵”受害者布伦达·伍德拉德16岁的妹妹詹妮弗·伍德拉德给威廉姆斯一家写了一封信，表达了她最深切的同情和感同身受的挣扎。她写道：“我知道世上所有的慰问卡和慰问信都无法抹去你此刻感受到的哪怕一丝痛苦。
A big part of living includes accepting the bad with the good, but why in God's name does such a large part of it have to be bad? One day, and I hope very soon, this insane maniac will be found. But until then, I hope and pray that another innocent girl will never fall into the hands of such an evil and purposeless death.'' Jennifer shared a poem which had brought her some comfort. It read, ''I cannot say and I will not say that she is dead. She is just the way. With a cheery smile and a wave of the hand, she has wandered into an unknown land,
生活很大一部分包括接受坏事与好事，但为什么上帝保佑，其中这么大一部分必须是坏事呢？总有一天，我希望很快，这个丧心病狂的疯子会被找到。但在那之前，我希望并祈祷另一个无辜的女孩永远不会落入如此邪恶和毫无意义的死亡之手。”詹妮弗分享了一首曾给她带来一些慰藉的诗。诗中写道：“我不能说，我也不会说她已经死了。她只是换了一种方式。带着灿烂的微笑和挥手，她漫步走入了一个未知的国度，
and left us dreaming how very fair its needs must be since she lingers there. So think of her fairing on as dear in the love of there as the love of here. Think of her still as the same I say, for she is not dead. She is just the way.'' With the Freeway Phantom now active once again, investigators and the media began reflecting over the similarities between each known victim. Some remained uncertain whether 14-year-old Angela Barnes had fallen prey to the Freeway Phantom, as she was the only girl to sustain a gunshot wound and did not exhibit any signs of sexual assault. Many felt her murder was committed by another individual entirely. The densely populated areas where each of the
留给我们遐想，既然她在那里流连，那里的需求一定多么美好。所以，请想象她在那里的爱中，就像在这里的爱中一样，过着同样亲爱的人生。请依然把她想象成和从前一样，因为她没有死。她只是换了一种方式。”随着“高速公路幽灵”再次活跃起来，调查人员和媒体开始反思每个已知受害者之间的相似之处。一些人仍然不确定14岁的安吉拉·巴尔内斯是否成为了“高速公路幽灵”的猎物，因为她是唯一一个遭受枪伤且没有表现出任何性侵迹象的女孩。许多人觉得她的谋杀完全是另一个人干的。
seven victims had lived presented a contrasting mix of middle-class family homes and public housing projects, where the streets were poorly lit and there were many run-down neglected areas. The killer's hunting grounds were east of the Anacostia River, far from DC's tourist hotspots, where the residential enclaves were bisected with highways and parks, making it popular with transients. Most of the girls had come from well-educated, middle- or working-class families with varying social and economic status, who either lived in homes on quiet, treeline streets or in apartment buildings. Each girl was similar in physical appearance, indicating the killer always had a specific target in mind. Despite their age difference, all were black, slim, tall and well
七名受害者所居住的人口稠密地区呈现出一种对比鲜明的混合面貌，既有中产阶级家庭住宅，也有公共住宅项目，那里的街道光线昏暗，有许多破败被忽视的地区。凶手的狩猎场在阿纳科斯蒂亚河以东，远离特区的旅游热点，那里的住宅区被高速公路和公园纵横交割，因此很受流浪人员欢迎。大多数女孩都来自受过良好教育的中产阶级或工人阶级家庭，有着不同的社会和经济地位，她们要么住在安静、绿树成荫的街道上的房屋里，要么住在公寓楼里。每个女孩的外貌都很相似，这表明凶手心中始终有着一个特定的目标。尽管年龄有差异，但所有人都是黑人，身材苗条、高挑且穿着
dressed. Captain Robert Boyd from the Washington Metropolitan Homicides Squad explained, their physical description was about the same. The older girls looked younger and the younger girls looked older. They looked between 14 and 16. The theory that their killer was targeting girls with the middle name of Denise was losing merit, as the latest victim Diane Williams had no association with the name. The locations where each body was found were also similar, with a remarkable lack of clues or physical evidence. The killer more than likely had access to a vehicle, carrying out the rapes and murders elsewhere to purposefully limit any evidence left behind. The disposal of the bodies at night or in the early hours appeared
得体。华盛顿大都会凶杀案组的罗伯特·博伊德队长解释说，她们的外貌特征几乎完全一样。年长的女孩看起来更年轻，年轻的女孩看起来更老。她们看起来都在14到16岁之间。凶手以中间名为“丹尼斯”的女孩为目标的理论正在失去效力，因为最新的受害者黛安·威廉姆斯与这个名字没有任何关联。发现每具尸体的地点也很相似，显著缺乏线索或物证。凶手极有可能拥有交通工具，在别处实施强奸和谋杀，以刻意限制留下的任何证据。在夜间或清晨处理尸体似乎
to be a tactic that took advantage of the cover of darkness, while enabling the killer to easily spot the headlights of approaching cars. How the freeway phantom lured his victims was a point of contention. With the exception of Nana Mosier Yates and Brenda Woodard, no other victims carried obvious defensive injuries, nor were there any signs of a struggle in the area of their abduction. Either the girls knew their killer and voluntarily entered his car, or he was respectfully presented and well articulated enough to convince them to accept the ride. Some criminal profilers believed the killer was likely a middle class, older, black male. They didn't rule out the possibility he was Caucasian, but were certain locals would have recalled a white man frequenting
是一种战术，既利用了夜色的掩护，又使凶手能够轻松发现迎面驶来的汽车车灯。“高速公路幽灵”是如何诱捕受害者的这一点存在争议。除了南娜·莫西尔·耶茨和布伦达·伍德拉德之外，其他受害者都没有明显的防御性伤势，在她们被绑架的区域也没有任何挣扎的迹象。要么是这些女孩认识凶手并自愿上了他的车，要么是他的外表和言谈举止足够体面，足以说服她们接受搭车。一些犯罪侧写师认为，凶手很可能是中产阶级、年龄较大的黑人男性。他们并不排除他是白人的可能性，但确信当地人会记得有个白人频繁出没于
the area. He could have also disguised himself as a woman, or had a female accomplice to earn his victims trust. The killer's propensity for strangulation was more commonly associated with criminals from a middle or upper class background. A psychologist who worked with sex offenders, Dr. Murray Cowan, concluded that the killer likely presented himself as gentle, well-meaning, and in control, while hiding a bitter hatred. He believed the murders were fueled by rage, and that the sexual assaults were a secondary motive, providing an additional outlet for anger expression and degradation. The killer appeared familiar with the southeast area, possibly from having lived in Washington for a long period of time while working a job that
该地区。他也可能把自己伪装成女性，或者有一个女性同伙来赢得受害者的信任。凶手对勒颈的偏好通常与中产阶级或上层阶级背景的罪犯有关。曾与性犯罪者合作过的心理学家默里·库万博士得出结论，凶手可能表现得温和、善意且情绪稳定，同时隐藏着一种痛苦的仇恨。他认为这些谋杀是由愤怒驱动的，而性侵犯则是次要动机，为情绪的宣泄和贬低提供了另一个出口。凶手似乎对东南地区很熟悉，这可能是因为他在华盛顿长期居住过，且从事的工作
required him to travel around the city. He may have crossed paths or come into contact with these victims in the past, and this recognition allowed them to interact with him with little concern. Male teachers, including substitute teachers within the southeast D.C. area were looked into, but none had taught all seven of the victims. There were also loose links between the fact that Diane Williams, Darlenea Johnson, and Brenda Woodard had summer jobs with the Department of Recreation, and that Nanomotia Yates and Carol Spinks lived near public parks and swimming pools. Recreation centers and popular youth spots were looked into, but this too was deemed a coincidence. Detective Lewis Richardson from the Washington Metropolitan Homicide Squad
需要他在全市到处奔波。他过去可能与这些受害者擦肩而过或有过接触，这种熟悉感使得她们与他互动时毫无戒心。包括东南特区代课老师在内的男性教师受到了调查，但没有一人教过所有七名受害者。黛安·威廉姆斯、达莱妮娅·约翰逊和布伦达·伍德拉德曾在娱乐部做过暑期工作，而纳诺莫蒂娅·耶茨和卡罗尔·斯平克斯住在公共公园和游泳池附近，这些事实之间也存在着一些松散的联系。娱乐中心和热门的青少年聚集地受到了调查，但这也被认为是一种巧合。华盛顿大都会凶杀案组的侦探刘易斯·理查森
voiced his opinion that members of the community were withholding information out of fear the killer would seek retribution. Quote, We believe someone has seen something, but they don't want to get involved. This man has confided in a close relative or friend. We're seeking this person to come forward, to save the next victim's life. Although there were no major developments over the following months, efforts were underway to improve coordination between the different agencies working on solving the case. This hindrance may have been the killer's intention, that abducting victims from one jurisdiction and leaving their bodies in another would result in a muddled investigation.
表达了他的看法，即社区成员因为害怕凶手会进行报复而隐瞒信息。“我们相信有人看到了什么，但他们不想卷入其中。这个人曾向某个近亲或朋友吐露过。我们呼吁这个人站出来，以挽救下一个受害者的生命。”尽管在接下来的几个月里没有取得重大进展，但各机构正在努力改善协调工作，以合力侦破此案。这种阻碍可能是凶手的意图，即从一个辖区绑架受害者并将尸体抛在另一个辖区，从而导致调查陷入混乱。
If this was indeed his tactic, some believed that the killer was a member of law enforcement, fully aware of the pitfalls of the force. This correlated well with the theory that the victims voluntarily accepted a riot from the killer, as they would have trusted or complied with a police officer. Several officers were investigated, but none were identified as suspects. Leads were followed up as far away as Mexico, and crimes that shared similar Ramos were checked for possible links. Allegations continued to surface that the police weren't taking the investigation seriously because of the victim's race, prompting Detective Richardson to respond defensively. I'm Black, and I'm from the ghetto, and in this city, a homicide is a homicide.
如果这确实是他的战术，一些人认为凶手可能是执法人员，十分清楚警方的种种漏洞。这与受害者自愿接受凶手搭车的理论不谋而合，因为她们会信任或服从警官。几名警官受到了调查，但无人被确定为嫌疑人。线索甚至追查到了远在墨西哥的地方，并且手法相似的犯罪也被排查以寻找可能的联系。关于警方因为受害者种族问题而没有严肃对待调查的指控不断浮出水面，促使侦探理查森进行了辩护性的回应：“我是黑人，我来自贫民窟，在这个城市里，命案就是命案。”
A body is a body, whether it's a banker or a junkie, they get the same attention. Contrary to popular opinion, the freeway phantom investigation had received a large amount of police attention. Many who worked on the case stated it was the largest manhunt they had ever been involved with. Hundreds of thousands of dollars and hours were poured into the case. Thousands of leads were investigated, and thousands of interviews were conducted. Maintaining his belief that someone was withholding information out of fear or loyalty, Detective Richardson said the community was just as responsible for helping uncover the truth. He finished with an apology. Quote,
不管尸体是银行家还是瘾君子，尸体就是尸体，他们得到的关注都是一样的。与流行观点相反，“高速公路幽灵”调查案受到了警方的高度关注。许多参与此案的人表示，这是他们参与过的最大规模搜捕行动。数以十万计的资金和工时被投入到了该案中。数千条线索被调查，数千次走访被进行。理查森侦探坚信有人出于恐惧或忠诚而隐瞒信息，他表示社区在帮助揭露真相方面负有同等的责任。最后他以道歉结束。原话是：
I'm sorry we haven't caught anyone. I feel we're letting the community down. By May 1973, the investigation had stagnated, and the number of detectives assigned to the case had dwindled to two. Wilma Harper, the aunt of Diane Williams, was in the process of writing a book about the case when she founded a support group for the victim's families, named the Freeway Phantom Committee. They bonded over their shared losses, with Brenda Crockett's mother, Rita, explaining, People have said to me, I know how you must feel, but they really don't know. They didn't lose a child like that. If mine is dead and yours is dead, then we can understand each
“很抱歉我们还没抓到任何人。我觉得我们辜负了社区。”到1973年5月，调查陷入停滞，分配到该案的侦探人数缩减到了两名。黛安·威廉姆斯的姑妈威尔玛·哈珀正在撰写一本关于此案的书，期间她创立了一个针对受害者家属的支持团体，名为“高速公路幽灵委员会”。他们因共同的失去而紧密联系在一起，布伦达·克罗克特的母亲丽塔解释道：“有人对我说，‘我懂你的感受’，但他们其实并不懂。他们没有失去过这样一个孩子。如果我的孩子死了，你的孩子死了，那我们就能互相
other. It's as simple as that. The unsolved murders had a profound impact on each family. Darlenea Johnson's sister was so terrified of intruders coming into their home that her family had to move. Carol Spinks' family also relocated, with her mother, Alan Teane, succumbing to the weight of public scrutiny. After being forced by police to take a lie detector test, rumors had circulated that she was protecting her daughter's killer. Some siblings of the victims struggled at school and were afraid to go anywhere alone. They distrusted men and had a general wariness of their community, with some developing a bitterness towards Washington DC as a whole.
理解。事情就是这么简单。”这些未破的谋杀案对每个家庭都产生了深远的影响。达莱妮娅·约翰逊的妹妹对闯入者进入他们家的恐惧达到了极点，以至于她的家人不得不搬家。卡罗尔·斯平克斯的家人也搬迁了，她的母亲阿兰·蒂恩最终没能承受住公众审视的重压。在被警方强制要求接受测谎仪测试后，有传言称她在保护女儿的凶手。受害者的一些兄弟姐妹在学校里苦苦挣扎，害怕独自去任何地方。他们不信任男性，对社区普遍抱有警惕心，有些人甚至对整个华盛顿特区产生了怨恨。
Acknowledging that the distrust of police held by the community might be preventing someone with information from coming forward, the committee questioned citizens themselves. They also rallied together to boost the reward money. Carol's mother, Alan Teane Spinks, quote, Our kids are gone now, but we have to find the person responsible for the sake of other children. The police say they have no clues and no suspects. I know someone out there knows a piece of the puzzle and money talks. Committee members appeared on talk shows, organized school safety programs, and held self-defense classes to keep the case in the public consciousness. The start of 1974 marked one year and nine months since the freeway phantom last
委员会承认社区对警察的不信任可能会阻止掌握线索的人站出来，于是他们亲自询问市民。他们还联合起来提高悬赏金。卡罗尔的母亲阿兰·蒂恩·斯平克斯说：“我们的孩子现在已经不在了，但为了其他孩子的安全，我们必须找到责任人。警察说他们没有线索，也没有嫌疑人。我知道外面有人知道拼图的一块碎片，而金钱能让人开口。”委员会成员出现在脱口秀节目中，组织学校安全项目，并举办自卫课程，以使公众的脑海中始终记着这个案子。1974年的开始标志着“高速公路幽灵”上次
struck. What caused the end of his killing spree remained a mystery, but the theories were that he had been arrested for an unrelated crime, being institutionalized, moved away, or died. Psychologists speculated that his crimes may have been triggered by a conflict in his life, which had since been resolved. On February 17, an article written by John Sa in The Washington Post revisited the racial issue. Calvin Rollark, the president of the Washington Highland Civic Association, stated, For years, blacks have been at the mercy of white-run police departments who held them at low priority as long as blacks were killing blacks, and I haven't seen much change in this. You will find a pattern of young blacks being missing and murdered,
作案已经过去了一年零九个月。是什么导致他的杀戮狂潮结束仍然是个谜，但种种推测认为他可能因不相关的罪行被捕、被送入收容机构、搬走了或者已经死亡。心理学家推测，他的犯罪可能是由生活中的冲突引发的，而该冲突此后已经得到解决。2月17日，《华盛顿报》上由约翰·萨尔撰写的一篇文章再次探讨了种族问题。华盛顿高地公民协会主席卡尔文·罗拉尔表示：“多年来，黑人在白人管理的警察部门的慈悲下生活，只要是黑人杀害黑人，他们就把这排在低优先级，而且我没看到有什么改变。你会发现年轻黑人失踪和被谋杀的模式，
and were never able to bring the individuals to justice. But if white folks are murdered, they don't stop investigating until they find out who did it. Washington Metropolitan Police Captain Robert Boyd disputed this vehemently, stating, nothing could be further from the truth. The article supported Captain Boyd's assertions through statistics, which showed in 1972 the closure rate for homicide cases was identical for black and white victims, and in 1973 cases involving white victims actually had a higher unsolved rate. Captain Boyd blamed the media for the widespread misconception that his department didn't take the murders of black people seriously. He maintained it was really the media that showed
而我们永远无法将这些人绳之以法。但如果是白人被谋杀，他们就不会停止调查，直到查出是谁干的。”华盛顿大都会警察局长罗伯特·博伊德对此进行了激烈的反驳，声称：“事实远非如此。”该文章通过统计数据支持了博伊德队长的断言，数据显示，1972年黑人和白人受害者谋杀案的结案率完全相同，而1973年涉及白人受害者的案件未破率实际上更高。博伊德队长指责媒体造成了广泛的误解，即他的部门不严肃对待黑人被谋杀的案件。他坚持认为，真正表现出
a calculated disinterest in reporting crimes committed in DC's black neighborhoods. He did accept that police had no excuse for why an arrest had not yet been made, calling the killer clever and tremendously lucky for carrying out his crimes without anyone witnessing. The publication of John Sarr's article generated renewed public interest, and in March 1974, the police launched a new inquiry into the Freeway Phantom case. Later that month, they received a phone call from a woman who said the article had taken its toll on her conscience, and she couldn't remain silent any longer. Based on the undisclosed tip-off she provided, on Saturday, April 6, it was announced that arrests had been made for the 1971 murder of
对报道特区黑人社区犯罪漠不关心的其实是媒体。他确实承认警方对于至今未能实施逮捕没有任何借口，并称凶手精明且运气极佳，能够在没有任何目击者的情况下实施犯罪。约翰·萨尔一文的发表重新唤起了公众的兴趣，1974年3月，警方对“高速公路幽灵”案展开了新的调查。当月晚些时候，他们接到了一名女性的电话，她称这篇文章触动了她的良心，她再也不能保持沉默了。根据她提供的未公开线索，在4月6日星期六，官方宣布已对1971年谋杀
14-year-old Angela Barnes. Edward Selman and Tommy Simmons met in 1970 while undergoing training at the Washington Metropolitan Police Academy. During their first year probation in early 1971, they reported having their police-issued 38-caliber firearm stolen from Simmons' home in Temple Hills. As there were no signs of forced entry and no other valuables were missing, major doubts were raised about their story. An internal inquiry was launched, and when faced with the possibility of disciplinary action, both Selman and Simmons resigned from the force. When questioned about Angela Barnes' murder, Simmons confessed to the crime, saying that in the late hours of July 12, 1971, he and Selman were driving his Volkswagen down Wheel of Road
14岁女孩安吉拉·巴尔内斯的凶手实施了逮捕。爱德华·塞尔曼和托米·西蒙斯于1970年在华盛顿大都会警察学院接受培训时相识。在1971年初的第一个实习年里，他们报告称，他们警用发放的38口径枪械在西蒙斯位于坦普尔希尔斯的家中被盗。由于没有强制进入的痕迹，也没有其他贵重物品丢失，他们的说法遭到了重大质疑。内部调查随之展开，面对可能面临纪律处分的可能性，塞尔曼和西蒙斯双双从警队辞职。当被问及安吉拉·巴尔内斯的谋杀案时，西蒙斯对罪行供认不讳，称在1971年7月12日的深夜，他和塞尔曼开着他的大众汽车沿东南
Southeast when they spotted Angela walking alone. They made a U-turn and forced her into their vehicle at gunpoint with the intention to, quote, take sexual advantage of her. When Angela tried to escape, Selman held the gun to her head and ordered her to hold still. A struggle ensued, during which he claimed the gun accidentally went off, killing her instantly. Panicked, they drove out to Waldorf where they disposed of her body, before driving back to Washington to clean blood from the vehicle. Selman denied any involvement, saying he had been at home that night with his wife playing Monopoly when Simmons knocked on his door, distressed, saying he had killed a girl and needed help disposing of the body. But his now ex-wife
惠勒路行驶时，看到安吉拉独自一人在走路。他们调头并持枪强迫她上车，意图“占她性氧化便宜”。当安吉拉试图逃跑时，塞尔曼将枪指着她的头部，命令她保持不动。双方随后发生争执，期间他声称枪支意外走火，当场将她打死。陷入恐慌后，他们开车前往沃尔多夫处理了尸体，随后开车返回华盛顿清洗车上的血迹。塞尔曼否认参与其中，称那天晚上他一直在家和妻子玩“大富翁”，这时西蒙斯敲响了他的门，神情痛苦地说他杀了一个女孩，需要帮忙处理尸体。但他的前妻
debunked his alibi and eventually testified against him, saying she had witnessed Selman destroy his gun in the days following the murder. Two days after Simmons and Selman's arrest, a police spokesperson announced that both men had been ruled out of the Freeway Phantom investigation and were not suspects in the remaining six unsolved murders. The pair were found guilty for the kidnapping and murder of Angela Barnes and sentenced to a minimum of 20 years to life in prison. Members of the Freeway Phantom Committee were relieved as it gave them hope that they too would receive closure in the future. However, they were aware that the community's distrust
揭穿了他的不在场证明，并最终出庭指证他，称她目睹了塞尔曼在谋杀发生后的几天里销毁了他的枪。在西蒙斯和塞尔曼被捕两天后，警方发言人宣布，这两人已被排除在“高速公路幽灵”调查之外，不是其余六起未破谋杀案的嫌疑人。两人因绑架和谋杀安吉拉·巴尔内斯罪名成立，被判处至少20年至终身监禁。“高速公路幽灵”委员会成员感到宽慰，因为这让他们燃起希望，即他们未来也能得到一个了结。然而，他们意识到，由于被定罪的男子曾是警官，社区对
in law enforcement would only increase as the convicted men were former officers. Diane Williams' aunt, Wilma Harper, quote. Most of the telephone calls we get criticised the police. The fact that they suspects were policemen saddens us. We know how the public feels toward the police, and this will make it harder for them. On June 5, 1974, it was announced that new and credible information had been obtained in relation to the Freeway Phantom case. The year prior, three men had been convicted for committing a string of violent kidnappings and sexual assaults against seven young women in the D.C. area. The attacks dated back to 1969 and shared the same ammo. The men would lure a woman into their car
执法部门的不信任只会进一步加深。黛安·威廉姆斯的姑妈威尔玛·哈珀表示：“我们接到的绝大多数电话都在批评警察。嫌疑人是警察这一事实让我们感到难过。我们知道公众对警察的看法，这会使他们更加艰难。”1974年6月5日，官方宣布获得了有关“高速公路幽灵”案的新且可信的信息。前一年，三名男子因在特区地区对七名年轻女性实施了一系列暴力绑架和性侵犯而被定罪。这些袭击可追溯到1969年，手法完全相同。这几名男子会将一名女性诱骗上车，
before driving to an abandoned building where they proceeded to rape her before dropping her off in the city. Given that the vehicle used was a green Chevrolet Vega, investigators named the gang the Green Vega Rapists. In October 1973, three men aged in their 20s were convicted for the crimes. As they served their time, additional charges were laid against them as more victims came forward. It was soon determined that at least five men had been involved and that the gang may have been responsible for up to 1,000 rapes committed between 1969 and 1973. As the new charges were piling up, one of the convicted men, Maris Warren, attempted to secure a plea deal with the prosecution, alleging that he had information about the Freeway Phantom.
然后开到一个废弃的建筑里对其实施强奸，之后再将她丢弃在城市中。鉴于使用的车辆是一辆绿色的雪佛兰维加轿车，调查人员将该团伙命名为“绿色维加强奸犯”。1973年10月，三名二十多岁的男子因这些罪行而被定罪。随着他们服刑，随着更多受害者的站出来，针对他们的额外指控也被提出。不久后确定，至少有五名男子涉案，且该团伙可能对1969年至1973年间多达1000起强奸案负责。随着新指控不断堆积，其中一名被定罪的男子马里斯·沃伦试图与检方达成认罪协议，声称他掌握关于“高速公路幽灵”的信息。
He proceeded to identify several of the Freeway Phantom victims as Green Vega targets, taking police to the crime scenes and providing details about how the girls were killed. Warren was convinced that other members of the gang were striking similar deals with the prosecution and wanted to be the first one to talk to ensure he secured the best possible bargain. However, the others were all remaining silent and when the prosecution refused Warren's offer of total immunity, he retracted his statements and admitted everything he said about the Green Vega Rapists' involvement with the Freeway Phantom case had been an elaborate lie. This came as little surprise to some investigators, as Warren only provided details that had been
他接着指认了几名“高速公路幽灵”受害者其实是“绿色维加”的目标，带着警察去犯罪现场并提供有关女孩们如何被杀的细节。沃伦确信该团伙的其他成员正在与检方达成类似的协议，并希望成为第一个开口的人以确保自己获得最佳协议。然而，其他人全部保持沉默，当检方拒绝了沃伦的全面豁免权提议时，他撤回了陈述，并承认他关于“绿色维加强奸犯”参与“高速公路幽灵”案的所有言论都是精心编造的谎言。这并没有让一些调查人员感到意外，因为沃伦提供的细节仅仅是
widely circulated in the media. He failed to mention any undisclosed information, like the handwritten note left in Brenda Woodard's pocket. Heirs found on the bodies of some of the victims were tested against Green Vega gang members with zero match. Despite this, some investigators were convinced Warren was telling the truth. A full police probe was conducted into the possible connection, but there was no evidence or witnesses to link the two cases together, and with Warren's statements now retracted, in 1976, a grand jury decided there was not enough evidence to issue an indictment. Four members of the gang were sentenced to life in
在媒体中广泛流传的内容。他未能提及任何未公开的信息，比如留在布伦达·伍德拉德口袋里的手写纸条。在某些受害者尸体上发现的毛发与“绿色维加”团伙成员进行了比对，结果完全不匹配。尽管如此，一些调查人员仍然确信沃伦说的是实话。警方对这一可能的联系进行了全面的调查，但没有证据或目击者将这两起案件联系起来，随着沃伦现在撤回了陈述，1976年，大陪审团认为没有足够的证据提起起诉。该团伙的四名成员因参与
prison for their involvement with the Green Vega attacks, each of whom denied any involvement with the Freeway Phantom case. In March 1977, 58-year-old computer technician Robert Askins was arrested in D.C. for the kidnapping and rape of a 24-year-old woman. Askins had previously spent several years in the St. Elizabeth Hospital after pleading not guilty by reason of insanity for the 1938 murder of a sex worker named Ruth MacDonald, who he had poisoned to death using cyanide laced whiskey. His sentence was later overturned on a legal technicality, and he was released from the psychiatric facility in 1958. After his latest rape charge, the police conducted a search of
“绿色维加”袭击而被判处无期徒刑，每个人都否认自己与“高速公路幽灵”案有任何关联。1977年3月，58岁的计算机技术员罗伯特·阿斯金斯在特区因绑架和强奸一名24岁女性而被捕。阿斯金斯此前曾因1938年用氰化物浸泡过的威士忌毒死一名名为露丝·麦克唐纳的性工作者而以精神失常为由作无罪辩护，在圣伊丽莎白医院度过了几年。他的刑期后来在法律技术细节上被推翻，并于1958年从精神病设施释放。在他最近的强奸指控之后，警方对
Askins' property, where homicide detective Lloyd Davis came across the appellate court decision relating to his release from St. Elizabeth's. Something in the documents caught his eye, the word Tantamount. The same word featured in the note from the Freeway Phantom found in Brenda Woodard's coat pocket. As it wasn't a word he heard often, it stuck out to Detective Davis, and he wondered whether Askins could have been responsible for the crimes. Detective Davis questioned Askins' former colleagues, who confirmed he often used the word Tantamount when expressing important matters. A search of Askins' home uncovered photos of young girls, soiled women's scarves, and a knife that was linked to another unsolved crime. A gold earring
阿斯金斯的财产进行了搜查，凶杀案侦探劳埃德·戴维斯偶然翻到了有关他从圣伊丽莎白医院释放的上诉法院判决书。文件中的某个词吸引了他的注意：Tantamount（同等重要）。这个词也出现在布伦达·伍德拉德大衣口袋里发现的“高速公路幽灵”纸条中。由于这不是一个他经常听到的词，它引起了戴维斯侦探的注意，他开始怀疑阿斯金斯是否应该对这些罪行负责。戴维斯侦探盘问了阿斯金斯的前同事，他们证实他在表达重要事情时经常使用“Tantamount”这个词。对阿斯金斯家中的搜查发现了一些年轻女孩的照片、弄脏的女性围巾，以及一把与另一桩未破谋杀案有关的刀。一枚金耳环
and two buttons were found in his vehicle, but no fibers were found that matched those on the bodies of several Freeway Phantom victims. Askins was questioned at length regarding the Freeway Phantom murders, but he denied involvement, saying he wasn't depraved enough to commit such crimes. He was convicted for the kidnapping and rape of the 24-year-old woman and another victim, and was sentenced to life in prison. Although there was no physical evidence to link him to the Freeway Phantom murders, he was considered by some to be the prime suspect. In 1987, former Washington Metropolitan Homicide Detective Romaine Jenkins was reassigned to the U.S. Attorney's Office. Jenkins had worked on the Freeway Phantom investigation since the
他的车里发现了两颗纽扣，但没有找到与几位“高速公路幽灵”受害者身上相符的纤维。阿斯金斯曾就“高速公路幽灵”谋杀案接受了长时间的盘问，但他否认涉案，称自己没有变态到去犯下这种罪行。他因绑架和强奸那名24岁女子及另一名受害者而被定罪，并被判处终身监禁。尽管没有物证将他与“高速公路幽灵”谋杀案联系起来，但一些人仍然认为他是主要嫌疑人。1987年，前华盛顿大都会警察局凶杀案侦探罗曼·詹金斯被重新调配到美国检察官办公室。詹金斯自
beginning, becoming invested from the moment she canvassed homes in Carol Spinks' neighborhood. With the resources of the U.S. Attorney's Office now at her disposal, Jenkins formally reopened the case. She re-interviewed witnesses, questioned friends and relatives of the victims, and visited key locations. While Jenkins believed Robert Askins was capable of committing such crimes, she was not convinced that he was the killer. She thought the person responsible was more likely a transient, a member of the military, a Vietnam war veteran suffering from post-traumatic stress disorder, or someone who felt they had a score to settle with the police. As a black woman herself, Jenkins agreed that the race of the victims had played a part in the
最初起就一直在参与“高速公路幽灵”调查，从她在卡罗尔·斯平克斯的社区走访居民的那一刻起，她就全身心投入了其中。如今，凭借美国检察官办公室的资源供她调遣，詹金斯正式重新启动了该案。她重新盘问了证人，询问了受害者的亲友，并实地考察了关键地点。虽然詹金斯相信罗伯特·阿斯金斯有能力犯下此类罪行，但她并不确信他就是凶手。她认为，作案者更有可能是一个流浪汉、一名军人、一个患有创伤后应激障碍的越南战争老兵，或者是一个觉得与警察有旧账要算的人。作为一名黑人女性，詹金斯承认受害者的种族在
initial mishandling of the investigation, but also blamed the general disorganization of the police departments involved for not being able to solve the crime. Given the significant advancements in forensic technology that had emerged since the 1970s, she requested the physical evidence found on the victims' bodies, including the note from Brenda Woodard's pocket, be tested for traces of DNA. However, most of the physical evidence had either been lost, destroyed, or preserved so poorly that nothing was in a condition to yield any conclusive results. Jenkins retired in 1994 and remained haunted by the unsolved case, reflecting on it daily and often re-reading her notes to see if there was any small detail she may have overlooked. In an interview with
调查初期的处理不当问题中起到了一定作用，但也指责涉案警察局普遍存在的混乱管理导致案件未能侦破。鉴于20世纪70年代以来法医技术的显著进步，她请求对在受害者尸体上发现的物证（包括布伦达·伍达德口袋里的字条）进行DNA痕迹检测。然而，大多数物证要么已经丢失、损毁，要么保存得如此糟糕，以至于没有任何样本处于能够得出任何确凿结果的状态。詹金斯于1994年退休，但这个未破的案件一直令她魂牵梦绕，她每天都在反思，并经常重读笔记，看是否有任何自己可能忽略的微小细节。在接受
The Washington Post, she declared that she will keep searching for answers until the day she dies. Quote, What happens when people like me and the families are gone? This will be forgotten. In 2004, the case was reopened once again by Washington Metropolitan Police Department Detective James Traynham. By this time, many of the original police files had been lost, and the ones he was able to recover from the FBI and Prince George's County were missing multiple pages and essential information. Detective Traynham thought it was important to look at the case from a fresh angle and employed the help of a former Canadian police
《华盛顿邮报》采访时，她宣称自己将至死都在寻找答案。她引述道：“当像我和受害者家属这样的人都不在了，会发生什么？这件事将被遗忘。”2004年，华盛顿大都会警察局侦探詹姆斯·特雷纳姆再次重启了该案。此时，许多最初的警察档案已经丢失，而他从联邦调查局和乔治王子县找回的档案也缺失了多页以及重要信息。侦探特雷纳姆认为，从一个全新的角度来看待这个案件非常重要，于是他寻求了一位前加拿大警察
officer turned criminology professor, Dr. Kim Rossmo from Texas State University. Rossmo had developed a computer program that used the geographic areas of a crime to help determine where the suspect may work or live, known as their anchor point. The system concluded that the freeway phantom likely had an anchor point in DC's Congress Heights District, somewhere on the south side of the St. Elizabeth Hospital. This aligned with Detective Traynham's belief that the killer lived in the same neighborhood as the first two victims, Carol Spinks and Darlenea Johnson, before he expanded elsewhere in an effort to detract attention from himself. In a revived plea for information, it was announced that a $150,000
转行的犯罪学教授、德克萨斯州立大学的吉姆·罗斯莫博士的帮助。罗斯莫开发了一个计算机程序，利用犯罪的地理区域来帮助确定嫌疑人可能工作或居住的地方，即所谓的锚点。该系统得出结论认为，“高速公路幽灵”的锚点很可能在华盛顿特区的国会山庄区，位于伊丽莎白医院南侧的某个地方。这与侦探特雷纳姆的看法一致，即凶手在将作案范围扩大到其他地方以转移人们对自己的注意力之前，就住在前两名受害者卡罗尔·斯平克斯和达尔琳娅·约翰逊的同一个社区。在一项重新发起的提供线索的呼吁中，官方宣布悬赏
reward was now available for anyone with a tip that led to an arrest. In 2009, the human hair found in Diane Williams' mouth was submitted to the FBI for advanced DNA testing, but the authorities remained tight lipped about the results. Like Detective Jenkins before him, Detective Traynham was not convinced that Robert Askins was the killer, telling The Washington Post that the police tried their best to make him fit the profile, but it simply wasn't working. On Friday, April 30, 2010, Robert Askins died in prison, aged 91 years. Detective Traynham retired without ever getting the answers he so desperately saw. For almost 50 years, the families of Carol Spinks, Darlenea Johnson, Brenda Crockett,
15万美元，向任何提供线索并促成逮捕的人发放。2009年，在黛安·威廉姆斯嘴里发现的人类毛发被送交联邦调查局进行高级DNA检测，但当局对检测结果闭口不谈。就像前任侦探詹金斯一样，侦探特雷纳姆并不确信罗伯特·阿斯金斯就是凶手，他在接受《华盛顿邮报》采访时表示，警方尽了最大努力让他符合画像，但根本行不通。2010年4月30日，星期五，罗伯特·阿斯金斯在狱中去世，终年91岁。侦探特雷纳姆退休时仍未得到他极其渴望的答案。近50年来，卡罗尔·斯平克斯、达尔琳娅·约翰逊、布伦达·克罗克特、
Nanomotia Yates, Brenda Woodard and Diane Williams have awaited justice. In a 2018 interview with journalist Cheryl Thompson for The Washington Post, Bertha Crockett said she still beats herself up for not going to the store with Brenda on the day she was abducted. Her trauma manifested in a rebellious streak in her youth. If Brenda was living, I would have done things differently. I wish I would have grown up with her. We could have encouraged each other to be better women. Patricia Williams' entire world changed on the day she found out her sister Diane had been murdered. The search for the truth motivated her to become an officer with the Washington Metropolitan Police Department,
娜诺莫蒂娅·叶茨、布伦达·伍达德和黛安·威廉姆斯的家属一直在等待正义。在2018年接受《华盛顿邮报》记者谢丽尔·汤普森的采访时，伯莎·克罗克特表示，直到今天她还在为布伦达被绑架那天自己没有和她一起去商店而自责。她的创伤在她年轻时的叛逆性格中表现出来。如果布伦达还活着，我会采取不同的做法。我真希望自己能和她一起长大。我们本可以互相鼓励，成为更好的女性。帕特里夏·威廉姆斯的世界在她得知姐姐黛安被谋杀的那一天发生了彻底的改变。寻找真相的动机激励她成为了一名华盛顿大都会警察局的警官，
with the ultimate goal to catch the freeway phantom. Patricia has since retired from the police department and she hasn't had any contact from law enforcement for years. She has no idea if the case is still being reviewed and if so who is in charge or which department has what files that remain scattered over the three jurisdictions, D.C., Prince George's County and Maryland. Patricia told The Washington Post, quote, You never forget, there is no closure. Whoever did it has gotten away. They may be living somewhere else doing it again. It's not too late to say something. You have a whole generation of family members who would like to see someone brought to justice.
其最终目标就是抓到“高速公路幽灵”。帕特里夏此后已经从警察局退休，并且多年来一直没有与执法部门进行过任何联系。她根本不知道这个案件是否仍在被审查，如果是，谁在负责，或者哪个部门掌握着那些分散在三个司法管辖区（华盛顿特区、乔治王子县和马里兰州）的残存档案。帕特里夏告诉《华盛顿邮报》：“你永远不会忘记，根本没有所谓的释怀。凶手逍遥法外。他们可能住在其他地方并再次作案。现在发声还为时不晚。这里有一整代家属，都希望能看到有人被绳之以法。”
As of 2019, the freeway phantom remains unknown. The $150,000 reward is still available and anyone with information is encouraged to contact the Washington Police Department or the FBI. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
截至2019年，“高速公路幽灵”的身份仍然未知。15万美元的悬赏仍然有效，鼓励任何掌握线索的人联系华盛顿警察局或联邦调查局。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。